This show is sponsored by BetterHelp. You know, kids are always learning and growing, but as adults, sometimes we lose that curiosity. You know, is there anything new, maybe, that you would like to learn? I think you guys know, I spent about two years mastering the art of making bread, and it made my heart so happy.
本节目由BetterHelp赞助。你知道，孩子们总是在学习和成长，但作为成年人，有时我们却失去了那种好奇心。你知道，有什么新东西，也许是你一直想学的吗？我想你们也知道，我花了大约两年的时间来精通做面包的艺术，这让我的内心感到无比快乐。
Therapy can help you reconnect with your sense of wonder. If you're thinking of starting therapy, give BetterHelp a try. It's entirely online, designed to be convenient, flexible, and suited to your schedule. You just fill out a brief questionnaire to get matched with a licensed therapist, and you can switch therapists at any time
心理咨询可以帮助你重新找回惊奇感。如果你正在考虑开始心理咨询，不妨试试BetterHelp。它完全在网上进行，旨在提供便捷、灵活且适合你日程安排的服务。你只需填写一份简短的问卷，就能与有资质的咨询师匹配，并且你可以随时更换咨询师，
for no additional charge. I have found therapy to be of great value in my life, and you know it has helped me give myself permission to make the space to try new things and enrich my my life. And you know it has helped me give myself permission to make the space to try new things and enrich my personal life. Rediscover your curiosity with BetterHelp. Visit betterhelp.com slash ladies today to get 10% off your first month.
无需支付额外费用。我发现心理咨询对我的生活有着巨大的价值，你知道它帮助我允许自己腾出空间去尝试新事物并丰富我的生活。你知道它帮助我允许自己腾出空间去尝试新事物并丰富我的个人生活。通过BetterHelp重新发现你的好奇心。今天就访问 betterhelp.com slash ladies，首月即可享受10%的折扣。
That's betterhelp, H-E-L-P, dot com slash ladies. What's it like to trade crypto on Kraken? Let's say I'm in a state-of-the-art gym surrounded by powerful-looking machines. Do I head straight for the squat rack? I could, but this gym has options, like trainers, fitness pros, fodders to back me up. That's crypto on Kraken, powerful crypto tools backed by 24-7 support and multi-layered security. Go to kraken.com and see what crypto can be. Not investment advice. Crypto trading involves risk of loss.
网址是betterhelp.com斜杠ladies，拼写是H-E-L-P。在Kraken上交易加密货币是什么体验？假设我在一个配备了强悍外观机器的尖端健身房里。我是该直奔深蹲架吗？我可以，但这家健身房有很多选择，比如教练、健身专业人士和后盾支持。这就是Kraken上的加密货币，强大的加密工具背后有24/7的全天候支持和多层安全性。访问kraken.com，看看加密货币能带来什么可能。非投资建议。加密货币交易涉及亏损风险。
See kraken.com slash legal slash ca dash pru dash disclaimer for info on Kraken's undertaking to register in Canada. I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office Rewatch Podcast just for you.
有关Kraken在加拿大注册承诺的信息，请参见kraken.com斜杠legal斜杠ca斜杠pru斜杠disclaimer。我是珍娜·费舍尔。我是安吉拉·金西。我们一起出演过《办公室》。我们是好朋友。现在我们专门为你带来终极《办公室》重温播客。
Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind the scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office ladies. Hello. Hi there. Should we tell everyone how we walked in today? It was ridiculous.
每周我们都会剖析一集《办公室》，并分享只有两个亲历现场的人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是办公室女士。你好。嗨。我们要不要告诉大家我们今天是怎么走进来的？太离谱了。
It's that thing. I think when you're friends with someone, you start to like dress alike. Because we both showed up with our hair and braids. Carrying giant boxes. And then we realized they're the same exact box of items. Which we'll get to later. Yes.
就是那件事。我觉得当两个人是朋友时，你们开始喜欢穿一样的衣服。因为我们俩今天都扎着辫子出现。手里还提着巨大的纸箱。然后我们发现，它们竟然是完全一模一样的物品箱。我们稍后会讲到这个。是的。
But you said we should title this episode, Braids and Boxes. Braids and Boxes. Here we go. The actual title of the episode that we're breaking down today is Live in the Dream Part One. It is Season Nine, Episode 22, written by Nikki Schwartz Wright and directed by Jeffrey Blitz.
但你说我们应该给这一集起名叫《辫子与纸箱》。《辫子与纸箱》。我们开始吧。我们今天要剖析的这一集的实际标题是《活在梦中（上）》。这是第九季第22集，由尼基·施瓦茨·怀特编剧，杰弗里·布利茨执导。
Would you like a summary? So much. All right, in this episode, Jim is taking time off from Athlead to focus on his marriage. Wow. Big deal, finally. Andy quits Dunder Mifflin to pursue his dreams.
你想来个剧情梗概吗？非常想。好的，在这一集中，吉姆正从“绝胜体育”请假来专注于他的婚姻。哇。这可是件大事，终于开始了。安迪辞去了邓德米夫林的职务去追求他的梦想。
He's gonna be something. He might host a food show, he might dance, he might act. There's so many options for Andy. Anything goes. Anything could happen. Angela is mourning the confiscation of her cats. All her cats get taken away in this episode. To Saxworth.
他要有一番作为了。他可能会主持美食节目，可能会跳舞，也可能会演戏。安迪的选择太多了。一切皆有可能。什么事都可能发生。安吉拉正在哀悼她的猫被没收。在这一集中，她所有的猫都被带走了。送给萨克斯沃斯。
I don't know. I remember that. That made me laugh. I know. And finally, Dwight is going to receive his black belt, finally. In the place he loves most. Yes.
我不知道。我记得那个。那把我逗笑了。我也觉得。最后，德怀特终于要获得他的黑带了。在他最喜欢的地方。是的。
All right, to kick things off, we got a fan question from Emma L. in Waterloo, Ontario, Canada, who said, "'I wanna know everything about what it was like "'to work with Michael Imperioli as Sensei Billy. "'I think his storyline and chemistry with Rainn Wilson "'is pure genius. "'How did he come to be cast in this role?
好的，为了开个好头，我们收到了来自安大略省滑铁卢的Emma L.的一位粉丝提问，她说：“我想知道和迈克尔·因佩里奥利一起工作是什么体验，他在剧中饰演比利师傅。我觉得他的故事线以及与雷恩·威尔逊的化学反应简直是纯粹的天才。他是怎么被选中出演这个角色的？”
Well, Emma, we are very excited to let you know that we got to interview Michael Imperiali. We did! All about his time on the show, and his interview is our Fast Facts, one, two, and three today. So here you go. ["Fast Facts"] We're so thrilled to have you.
好吧，艾玛，我们非常高兴地告诉你，我们采访到了迈克尔·因佩里奥利。我们真的采访到了！全部都是关于他在剧中的时光，他的采访就是我们今天的“速记趣闻”第一、第二和第三部分。所以，给你。［“速记趣闻”］我们非常高兴你能来。
Thank you. I'm glad to be you. Thank you. I'm glad to be here. It was so crazy when I was watching this episode and then all of a sudden you popped up on my screen and it was just the week before I ran into you on the street in New York. It was right after that. Yeah. It was such crazy timing.
谢谢。很高兴认识你。谢谢。很高兴来到这里。太疯狂了，当我看着这一集的时候，突然你出现在我的屏幕上，而在那之前的一个星期，我刚在纽约的街头偶遇了你。就在那之后不久。是的。时间太巧了。
So thanks for being with us today. We'll just hop right in. So we always ask our guests, how did you get your job on the office? Rain told me that they Googled actors who were black belts. Your name came up. And my name was on a list. So I don't know how many other actors they went through before they got to me who had black,
所以谢谢你今天能和我们在一起。我们直接切入正题吧。我们总是问嘉宾，你是怎么得到《办公室》这份工作的？雷恩告诉我，他们用谷歌搜索了拥有黑带的演员。你的名字浮现了。我的名字在一个名单上。所以我不知道在找到我之前，他们排除了多少其他拥有黑带的演员，
maybe Chuck Norris and I don't know who else. And that was really it. And then I got the script and I thought it was really funny. And I mean, the show's great and really funny. And that was it. That was how I got it. Had you watched the show before? Yeah, like everybody on the planet pretty much.
也许有查克·诺里斯，我不知道还有谁。事情就是这样。然后我得到了剧本，我觉得它真的很好笑。我的意思是，这部剧很棒而且真的很好笑。事情就是这样。我就是这样得到这个角色的。你在之前看过这部剧吗？看过，基本上就像地球上的每个人一样。
Yeah, I thought it was really funny and it was really a fun sequence, a fun part of the episode. It's just so ridiculous. It was really fun to watch it again because I hadn't seen it in quite a long time and I was like, it's even funnier than it was when I first saw it and when I did it.
是的，我觉得它真的很好笑，而且这是一个非常有趣的桥段，是这一集中很有趣的一部分。它简直太荒谬了。再次看这一集真的很有趣，因为我已经很长时间没有看过它了，我想，它甚至比我第一次看的时候和拍摄的时候还要好笑。
It stands up pretty well to be ridiculous and funny. It really does. I loved since Billy, like how calm he was. And just matter of fact, when Dwight's doing all this crazy crap. Well, listen, there are three scenes that you're in, you know, one of them is the very first montage where Dwight's trying to kick the board, which is hilarious. Did you give Rain any tips or did he just like go for it? No, he just went for it. You know, I've done Korean martial arts, mostly taekwondo for
它经受住了时间的考验，既荒谬又搞笑。确实如此。我很喜欢比利师傅，比如他有多冷静。当德怀特在做所有这些疯狂的破事时，他却无比淡定。好吧，听着，你有三场戏，你知道，其中一场是第一个蒙太奇，德怀特试图踢板子，这太搞笑了。你给过雷恩什么建议吗，还是他直接就上了？不，他直接就上了。你知道，我练过韩国武术，主要是跆拳道，
like 22 years. And sometimes you do break boards, you know, that's that's part of like usually on a test, when you're going up a level or something, you do that as a, you know, you're testing your kind of accuracy and speed and things like that. And I've never gotten kicked in the balls doing that, but I've held boards for other people testing, especially for kids. Kids aren't as accurate as adults sometimes, and they'll kick your hands, and holding boards for people. I've gotten my hands pretty banged up. So that's kind of accurate.
大约练了22年。有时你确实会踢断木板，你知道，那是测试的一部分，通常在晋级或其他什么的时候，你会把它作为一个测试你的准确性、速度等方面的项目。我从来没有在做这个时被踢到蛋蛋，但我为其他测试的人扶过木板，特别是为小孩子们。小孩子们有时不像成年人那么精准，他们会踢到你的手，而且为别人扶木板时。我的手受过不少罪。所以这挺真实的。
That really happens. But he just went for it. I don't remember if he told me that he trained or not. I'm pretty sure he had not trained. He had not trained, yeah. It didn't seem like he did. But he just went for it and I mean it's just so silly and fun. It's so silly. And then the next one is the belt ceremony in the office, the place he loves the most, right? And then you couldn't
这确实会发生。但他直接就上了。我不记得他是否告诉过我他受过训练。我很确定他没有受过训练。他没有受过训练，是的。看起来确实不像。但他直接就上了，我的意思是它太傻气、太好玩了。太傻气了。然后下一场戏是办公室里的腰带授予仪式，他最喜欢的地方，对吧？然后你没办法
get the belt off him and he's kind of awkwardly thrusting at you and you're so, since I built, he's just like, this isn't gonna work, okay. He's trying his best to keep composure because that's what a martial artist does, right? He doesn't let his anger get the best of him. But in martial arts, a lot of the movements, most of them really come from the hips, from the center of the body.
把腰带从他身上解下来，他有点尴尬地向你挺胯，而你作为比利师傅，你只是觉得，这行不通，好吧。他尽最大努力保持镇定，因为那是武术家所做的，对吧？他不会让愤怒占据上风。但在武术中，许多动作，实际上大部分都来自臀部，来自身体的中心。
You know, that's really where you get your power if you're throwing a punch. You know, if you watch like athletes like golfers or baseball players or tennis players, you can see it. Those, yeah, those motions with the arms. Yeah. I have a really good forehand. I don't want to brag, but I have a really, well, now I'm bragging, but I have a really good forehand at tennis and I'm short and people don't expect it because it's all in that twist,
你知道，如果你要出拳，那真的是你力量的来源。你知道，如果你观察像高尔夫球手、棒球运动员或网球运动员这样的运动员，你能看出来。那些，是的，那些用手臂的动作。是的。我的正手打得非常好。我不想吹牛，但我有一个非常好的，好吧，现在我是在吹牛，但我的网球正手非常好，而且我很矮，人们对此没有预期，因为这一切都取决于那个扭转，
that torque from your hips. Yeah. A lot of the movements in martial arts come from the hips, like punches and blocks and kicks even, right? So I think that's what he was, he was figuring, I have to use my hips here, you know, even getting the belt, like everything we do comes from the hips and it wasn't necessary. I love that. That's my theory at least. Do you remember like breaking it all in that scene? Cause I remember watching it and I, I think there's no shots of me in this sequence
来自你臀部的扭矩。是的。武术中的许多动作都来自臀部，比如出拳、格挡甚至踢腿，对吧？所以我认为那就是他在想的事情，他心想，我这里必须使用我的臀部，你知道，甚至在拿腰带时，我们做的所有事情都来自臀部，虽然这并不是必要的。我喜欢这个。至少这是我的理论。你还记得那场戏里大家都笑场了吗？因为我记得我看的时候，我觉得
because they had to avoid me cause I couldn't keep it together. No, I lost it a few times. It was just so, you know, he's just so committed, you know. Fans wrote in and pointed out every time someone broke and it's, we're all, they clocked everybody. Except you, my memory, Michael, is that you were very good at keeping it together.
这个桥段里没有我的镜头，因为他们必须避开我，因为我根本憋不住。没有，我笑场了好几次。那真的是，你知道，他太投入了，你知道。粉丝们写信指出每个人笑场的时刻，而且我们都在，他们记录了每个人的笑场。除了你，迈克尔，我的记忆是，你非常擅长保持镇定。
Are you an actor that breaks a lot? Because I was so impressed. If it's really funny, yeah, sometimes. You know, on The Sopranos, the time everybody broke was when it was the mother, Livia's, post-funeral gathering at the Soprano house. And everybody's there, the whole family and all the gangsters and all the friends of the family. They're talking about this woman that everybody hated really and who hated everybody, trying to find nice things to say.
你是一个经常笑场的演员吗？因为我太佩服你了。如果真的很好笑，会的，有时会。你知道，在《黑道家族》中，所有人都在笑场的那次是母亲莉维亚在黑道家族房子的葬礼后聚会。每个人都在那里，整个家族、所有的黑帮成员以及家族的所有朋友。他们正在谈论这个每个人其实都讨厌而且讨厌所有人的女人，试图找出一些好听的话来说。
And then they play her favorite song, which was this really schmaltzy love song from Carousel sung in this very high pitched voice. And when they put that song on, everybody just lost it. And they tried to do it again and every time that song came on, everybody just lost it. And then they realized, well, we can't play the song, so let's just pretend we're listening to it. And that still didn't work to the point where the director started yelling at people.
然后他们播放了她最喜欢的一首歌，那是来自音乐剧《旋转木马》的一首非常感伤的情歌，用非常高亢的声音演唱。当他们播放那首歌时，所有人都彻底崩溃了。他们试着再拍一次，每当那首歌响起，所有人都彻底崩溃了。然后他们意识到，好吧，我们不能播放这首歌，所以我们只能假装在听它。但即使那样也不起作用，甚至到了导演开始对大家大喊大叫的地步。
Was totally out of character for him because he had directed a lot of our episodes and he was a sweetheart. But he just couldn't do the scene because we were just, it just became this thing that was just too ridiculous. It's hard to come back from that too. When you're gone, you know, when you're in that kind of laughter fit, it's so hard to come back.
这完全不符合他的性格，因为他导演了我们很多集，而且他是个大好人。但他就是无法完成这场戏，因为我们实在，它变成了一件太荒谬的事情。从那里面走出来也很难。当你笑场了，你知道，当你陷入那种狂笑中时，太难恢复了。
You have to stop. You have to, you need some time. Well, they, you know, the Brits call that corpsing. You know that, right? I do not know that. That's what they call it. That's a great term. Yeah, yeah know that, right? I do not know that. No, I didn't know that. That's what they call it. That's a great term.
你必须停下来。你必须，你需要一些时间。好吧，英国人把这叫做“崩场”（corpsing）。你知道这个，对吧？我不知道这个。他们就是这么叫的。真是个好词。是的，是的，你知道这个，对吧？我不知道这个。不，我不知道。他们就是这么叫的。真是个好词。
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. Because you're just dead. They call it corpsing, when you just can't stop laughing, which is a weird expression, right? It is, but I love it. That happened to Jenna and I when I had to tell her that Dwight put sprinkles in my freezer and I had to ask her if Roy had ever mercy killed
是的，是的，是的，是的。因为你就像死了一样。当你们笑得停不下来时，他们称之为“崩场”，这是个奇怪的表达，对吧？确实如此，但我很喜欢。我和珍娜就遇到过这种情况，当时我不得不告诉她德怀特把洒洒（猫）放进我的冰箱里，我不得不问她里伊（Roy）有没有安乐死过她的一只宠物。
one of her pets. We couldn't. Every time I said like the cat had clawed the peas, like the bag of peas, cause the cat was trying to get out of the freezer. They broke us for lunch. They were like, you're gone. You're coercing.
我们根本忍不住。每次我说那只猫抓了豌豆，比如一袋豌豆，因为那只猫试图从冰箱里逃出来。他们直接让我们去吃午饭了。他们说：“你们完了。你们在崩场。”
You need time. Forget it. Yeah, because at that point, everything's gonna be funny, no matter how you approach it. And it's infectious and it's uncontrollable. It's an interesting phenomenon. And you can't really explain it to anyone
你们需要时间。算了吧。是的，因为到了那个地步，无论你怎么处理，每件事都会变得很好笑。而且它是会传染的，是无法控制的。这是一个有趣的现象。你真的无法向任何人解释，
unless you're really, because you're acting, you're not supposed to laugh, right? Which makes it worse, I think. Makes it worse, yeah. It's like don't think of the word elephant or something. It's kind of like that. Well, speaking of laughing,
除非你身处其中，因为你在演戏，你不应该笑，对吧？这让情况更糟，我想。让情况更糟，是的。就像“不要去想大象这个词”之类的。有点像那样。好吧，说到笑场，
after the belt thrusting, we get to Dwight's demonstration, which is so incredible. I have to ask, with all of your experiences, anything he's doing in this scene accurate in any way, is he doing any actual moves here? You know, some of the basic techniques he's executing but he doesn't really know how to do them properly. Okay. Mm-hmm. Is Sensei Billy giving him a black belt like sort of patronizingly? Has he earned his black belt in your opinion? I think he's earned it. Well he said he's one of the most tenacious people
在挺胯之后，我们来到了德怀特的展示环节，这简直太不可思议了。我不得不问，以你的所有经验，他在这一场戏中所做的任何动作在任何方面都是准确的吗，他这里有做任何实际的动作吗？你知道，他执行了一些基本技术，但他并不知道如何正确地执行它们。好的。嗯-hmm。比利师傅给他黑带是带有一种屈尊俯就的感觉吗？在他获得黑带这件事上，以你的看法他配得上吗？我觉得他是配得上的。好吧，他说他是他见过最顽强的人之一。
he's ever seen. So I think that tenaciousness. You know, a black belt in martial arts, you have to remember is you're not competing or comparing your level of skill and your development to anyone else. It's about your progression. So you can have a black belt,
所以我觉得那种顽强。你知道，武术中的黑带，你必须记住，你不是在与其他人竞争或比较你的技能水平和发展。这是关于你自己的进步。所以你可以有两个黑带，
two black belts that have trained the same amount of time and one's a super great athlete, and one's not. And they're going to be very different martial artists, you know, because natural athleticism and stuff, you know, I mean, I'm 58, I still train, but you know, you see some of these kids at 25 doing stuff that's just incredible that I'm not going to do. I mean, I have basic techniques that I've worked on for many years that I'm comfortable with. I like the fitness of it, but even the belt levels and that kind of thing is about your own progress and what you've done. So I guess Sensibility, I love that we're talking about this. Like, Sensibility said he's very tenacious and he trained with someone for 20 years who ripped him off, right? Yeah. And I think Sensibility feels like that gives
两个训练了相同时间的黑带，其中一个是超级棒的运动员，另一个不是。他们会成为非常不同的武术家，你知道，因为天然的运动能力等等，你知道，我的意思是，我已经58岁了，我还在训练，但你知道，你看到其中一些25岁的孩子在做一些简直不可思议的事情，而我是不会去做的。我的意思是，我有一些练习了多年的基础技术，我对此感到很自在。我喜欢它的健身效果，但即使是腰带级别和这类事情，也是关于你自己的进展和你的付出。所以我想比利师傅，我很高兴我们谈到这个。就像，比利师傅说他非常顽强，而且他曾和某个人训练了20年，结果被那个人坑了，对吧？是的。并且我认为比利师傅觉得这让武术名声扫地，因为比利师傅真的信仰武术，并且认为这，这太可怕了，因为武术是一个，你知道，是一个伟大的合法的艺术形式或健身和训练方式以及所有这些事情。你知道，我也见过一些拥有黑带的人，他们拥有零运动天赋，但他们工作非常努力，他们确实拥有他们的基础技术，并且他们能够完成不同级别所提供的要求，你知道。所以这 realmente 是关于你自己的进步。我觉得这真的很美妙。
martial arts a bad name because Sensibility really believes in it and thinks this is, this is horrible because martial arts is, you know, is a great legitimate form of art or fitness and training and all those things. You know, and I've seen people who were black belts who and all those things. You know, and I've seen people who were black belts who had zero athleticism, but they worked really hard and they did have their basic techniques and they were able to kind of fulfill the requirements that the different levels offer, you know. So it's really about your own progress. I think that's really beautiful.
而且这也让我觉得，也许我也可以成为一个黑带，如果这真的是关于我自己的话。就像如果我真的认真对待这件事的话。只要你付出时间。是的，真的被这种关于这段旅程的想法所启发，这种致力于这件事的身体、精神和心灵的旅程。这真的是太美妙了，因为这对所有人都是开放的。是的。这真的是太美妙了，因为这对所有人都是开放的。是的。
And it's also making me feel like maybe I could be a black belt if it really is about me. Like if I really took this seriously. And you put the time in. Yes, like truly inspired by this idea of this journey, of this physical, mental, spiritual journey committing to this thing. That is like so beautiful that this is open to this thing. Yeah. That is like so beautiful that this is open to all people. Yeah.
我以前不知道这一点，我绝对爱极了。是的，你知道，我的主要老师，太孙康（Tae Sun Kang）大师已经教了，我想有40多年了，他把一生都奉献给了这个，对吧？他刚刚入选了跆拳道名人堂，对吧？这是一个终身成就。但他有很多跟随了他很多很多年的学生。
I did not know that and I absolutely love it. Yeah, you know, my main teacher, Grandmaster Tae Sun Kang has been teaching for, I think it's over 40 years, and he's dedicated his life to this, right? He just got inducted into the Taeekwondo Hall of Fame, right? This lifetime achievement. But he has a lot of students that have been with him for many, many, many years.
而最近的这次测试，他们每年举行两次黑带测试。他在纽约地区有好几所学校。最近的这次测试中，三位年过50的女性都获得了第四段黑带。太棒了。太厉害了。那批学员中成绩最高的那几个，那是去年的11月、12月，
And this last test, they have a black belt test twice a year. And he has a couple of schools in the New York area. The last test, three women all over 50 got fourth degree black belts. That's amazing. That's awesome. The highest testers of that batch, that was last November, December,
是三位50多岁、接近60岁的女性。哇。好吧，作为一个今年刚满50岁的女性，我真的觉得这太美妙了。是的，看到去年的那个胜出者，那三位女性获得，你知道，成为成绩最高者并都获得了第四段黑带，这真的很酷，这意味着她们都已经训练了，你知道，
were three women over 50, close to 60. Wow. Well, as a woman who just turned 50 this year, I just think that's so beautiful. Yeah, it was really cool to see that last winner, those three women get, you know, as the highest testers and get all getting fourth degree black belts, which means they've all been training, you know,
20年，也许20多年。哇。太酷了。这激励了我。我的嫂子，年龄和我们差不多，珍娜，她这周刚刚拿到了黑带。我为她感到骄傲。她在科罗拉多州，但她已经学习了很长时间。所以能和您今天交谈，以及谈到比利师傅和
20 years, maybe 20 plus years. Wow. That's so cool. That inspires me. My sister-in-law who's around our age, Jenna, got her black belt this week. And I was so proud of her. She's in Colorado, but she's been studying a long time. And so it was just sort of really cool that we were talking to you today and Sensei Billy and
所有这些，感觉真的很酷。所以我告诉她，我说，好样的，女孩。是的，这是一个保持身材的好方法。你知道，对我来说，当我开始的时候，我的体形真的很糟糕。我抽烟，喝酒，而且根本不锻炼。我的孩子开始去学。我会去接他们并在一旁观看之类的。那是22年以前的事了。慢慢地，我开始了，我最终意识到我可以……我必须二选一，是抽烟还是练跆拳道，因为它们根本无法兼顾。而且，你知道，它让我踏上了一条健康的道路。其中有一种谦逊的态度，以及尊重的事情，
all of that. So I told her, I was like, way to go, girl. Yeah, it's a really great way to stay fit. You know, for me, when I started, I was really out of shape. I was smoking cigarettes, I was drinking, and I wasn't exercising at all. My kids started going. I would go pick them up and watch and stuff. This is 22 years ago. Slowly, I started and I eventually realized I can either... I had to choose one, smoking cigarettes or doing Taekwondo because they didn't Go together and you know, it started me on a path of health. There's a humility to it and the thing of respect and
想想达成目标、超越目标和挑战自己，我喜欢的一点是，我一直很难坚持一个健身房计划，因为我对使用力量器械等东西感到厌烦。而这是关于学习一项技能，在你上课的那一个小时里，你什么也想不了。这不像你在跑步机上看着CNN或查看电子邮件。
Think about meeting goals and exceeding goals and challenging yourself and what I liked I always had problems Committing to a gym program because I would get bored doing weight machines and things like that. This is about learning a skill, and for that hour that you're doing a class, you can't think about anything else. It's not like you're on a treadmill watching CNN or checking emails.
除了当下正在做的事情之外，你真的什么也想不了，因为它需要你所有的专注力。这对我有很大的帮助。我喜欢这样。我在网球场上也有同感。你不能思考，你没有手机，你什么也想不了。
You can't really think of anything else except what you're doing in the moment because it takes all that concentration. That was really helpful for me. I love that. I feel the same way on a tennis court. You can't think, you don't have your phone, you can't think of anything.
我把表摘下来，因为我不想让它震动或什么的。是的。是的，那太棒了。好吧，迈克尔，你有什么记忆吗？我知道你只去过片场那一次，但你对和我们在一起的片场时光有什么记忆，或者关于你在《办公室》的时光有什么幕后趣事吗？
I take my watch off because I don't want it buzzing or anything. Yeah. Yeah, that's great. Well, Michael, do you have any memories? I know you were only on set that one time, but do you have any memories from being on the set with us or any behind the scenes thing about your time
我有点惊讶它所在的那个地方。这是一个非常偏僻的地方，它在荒郊野岭，不是吗？是的，我们很喜欢它。它对面是铁路线。那里甚至有一只拴着链子的后院狗。我本以为我会去，你知道的，
on the office? I was kind of surprised where it was. It was this really out of the way, it was nowhere, wasn't it? It was, we loved it. It was across from train tracks. There was like a backyard dog on a chain. I thought I was going to like, you know,
索尼片场或者某种好莱坞传奇外景地。我喜欢那些大型传奇的老片场。那挺有趣的，对吧？是的，它们很漂亮。但它根本不是那种地方。不，不，不。有一次我们去了环球影城片场，
the Sony lot or some kind of, you know, Hollywood kind of legendary. I like those big legendary old lots. It's kind of fun, right? Yeah, they're pretty. But it wasn't anything like that. No, no, no. One time we went to the Universal Studios lot
为了拍，我不知道，比如照片库拍摄什么的。然后我们就像，伙计们，这里有食堂。这里有健身房。就像，我们当时惊叹。这里有健身房，是的。有些地方什么都有。你知道，我们在周边地区拍了很多戏，他们试图在洛杉矶找一个
for, I don't know, like a photo gallery shoot or something. And we were like, guys, there's a cafeteria. There's a gym. Like, we're like. It's a gym, yeah. Some of them have everything. You know, we shot a lot in the surrounding area and they kind of tried to find a part of LA
没有那么多棕榈树的区域，这样我们就可以直接走到街上拍外景。所以我想这也是其中的一部分。有点工业感，一点也不西海岸风，是的。没错，为了那种感觉。好吧，我不得不问，你有没有被认出来过
that didn't have all the palm trees so that we could just walk out onto the street and do exterior stuff. So I think that was kind of part of it. Kind of industrial and not at all West coasty, yeah. Exactly. To have that feel a little bit. Well, I have to ask, do you ever get recognized
是扮演比利师傅的演员？这种情况经常发生吗？哦，经常。真的吗？经常，是的。这对我来说太疯狂了。经常，因为这是一部，你知道，我的意思是，这是一部非常受欢迎的剧。我的意思是，克里斯托弗肯定是排在第一位的，对吧？克里斯托弗排第一，
as Sensei Billy? Does it come up? Oh, a lot. Really? A lot, yeah. That's so crazy to me. A lot because it's such, you know, I mean, it's such a popular show. I mean, it's gotta be Christopher first, right? Christopher first,
因为那是，你知道，我最广为人知的角色。但是的，人们从那个角色中认出了我。我的意思是，有时我有一些，你知道，当我去参加开幕式或活动之类的事情时，人们会，你知道，他们拿着照片等候着你。有时那是比利师傅的照片。哦，真的吗？是的。是的。是的。好吧，我有点喜欢这样。那太令人难忘了。
cause that's, you know, what I'm known for. But yeah, people remember me from that. I mean, sometimes I have some, you know, when they go to openings or events or stuff like that, people have, you know, they have waiting for you with photographs. Sometimes they're sensibility photos. Oh, really? Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Well, I kind of love that. It was very memorable.
是的，我们太高兴了。是的，你能来客串真的是一件非常、非常酷的事情。你今天能来和我们谈论这件事真的很好、很酷。谢谢你。谢谢。是的，这是一段非常美好的时光。他是一个非常优秀的演员。我的意思是，和雷恩一起工作真的很有趣。他非常、非常投入。非常像他的角色，对吧？
Yeah, we were so delighted. Yeah, it was a really, really cool thing that you came and did that. It was really neat and really cool that you came and talked to us about it today. Thank you. Thank you. Yeah, it was a really good time. He's a very good actor. I mean, it was really fun to work with with Rain. He's very, very committed. Very much like his character, isn't he?
是的。非常投入而且非常、非常搞笑。非常感谢你，迈克尔。这太棒了。谢谢。谢谢邀请我。我们很快再见。保重。
Yes. Very committed and just so, so funny. Thanks so much, Michael. This was wonderful. Thank you. Thanks for having me. We'll see you soon. Take care.
拜拜。好的。刚才那段多棒啊！太有趣了。我太喜欢他在现实生活中也是个黑带了。我喜欢那段对话大部分都是关于武术的。我也是。好吧，听着，迈克尔，非常感谢你来到办公室女士播客。
Bye bye. All right. How great was that? So fun. I just love that he is a black belt in real life. I love that the majority of that conversation was about martial arts. Me too. Well listen, Michael, thank you so much for stopping by Office Ladies.
你知道，他有一部电影将在12月上映。它叫《加拿大》，由保罗·施拉德执导。主演有理查德·基尔、乌玛·瑟曼、雅各布·埃尔洛迪和迈克尔·因佩里奥利，他说这部电影很棒。他说这是理查德·基尔有史以来最好的表演之一。我等不及要看了。好吧，听着，我们为什么不休息一下呢？当我们回来时，我们将深入探讨《活在梦中（上）》，
You know, he has a movie coming out in December. It is called Oh Canada and it's directed by Paul Schrader. It is starring Richard Gere, Uma Thurman, Jacob Elordi, and Michael Imperioli, and he said it's great. He said it's one of Richard Gere's best performances ever. I can't wait to see it. Well, listen, why don't we take a break? And when we come back, we will dive into Live in the Dream Part 1,
你会发现我们巨大的纸箱里装的是什么。是的，你会的。-♪ 是的，你会的。优步打车返现。坦白说，我是为了省钱来的，不管你认为大学是用来干什么的。加入Uber One学生版，这是一个在优步和优步外卖上省钱的会员计划。优惠力度这么大，每个人都想成为学生。每月只需4.99美元即可加入。节省金额可能会有所不同。适用资格和会员条款。寻找加速职业发展的途径？寻找迈向下一层级成功的明确方向？在一个创新且务实的地方，一个保持与行业前沿紧密联系的途径，一个你可以
and you'll find out what's in our giant boxes. Yes, you will. -♪ Yes, you will. Uber Cashback on rides. Just to be clear, I'm there for savings, not whatever you think university is for. Get Uber One for Students, a membership to save on Uber and Uber Eats. With deals this good, everyone wants to be a student. Join for just $4.99 a month. Savings may vary. Eligibility and member terms apply. Looking for a path to accelerate your career? Clear direction for next-level success? In a place that is innovative and practical, a path to stay current and connected to industry, a place where you
做自己的地方，你将在约克大学继续教育学院找到这一切，我们为你量身定制了职业课程。访问continue.yorku.ca 我们回来了，这是《活在梦中（上）》，在我们开始剖析这一集之前，今天我们有一位特殊的嘉宾来到这里，我们想向她致意，我们以前从没这样做过，《综艺》杂志的主编凯特·亚瑟加入了我们。嗨，凯特。嗨，凯特。
can be yourself, you will find it at York University School of Continuing Studies where we offer career programs purpose-built for you. Visit continue.yorku.ca We are back it's living the dream part one and before we start breaking down the episode we have a special guest here today we want to give a shout out we've never had this done before but Kate Arthur the, the editor at large at Variety is joining us. Hi Kate. Hi Kate.
我都不知道我要被致意了。这太不可思议了。你当然会的。你在这里，你是我们的嘉宾。我们的嘉宾都会受到致意。没错。我很高兴能来到这里。好吧，我们听说你和你的儿子
I didn't know I was getting a shout out. That's incredible. Of course you are. You're here, you're our guest. Our guests get shout outs. That's right. I'm so happy to be here. Well, we heard that you and your son
有时会在车里听办公室女士播客。我们当然听，是的。为我所有的粗口感到抱歉。没关系，他喜欢。但我们为你儿子准备了一小袋精美的小礼品。太可爱了，谢谢。他会喜欢的。
listen to office ladies in the car sometimes. We sure do, yes. Sorry for all my bulls**t cards. That's okay, he likes it. But we put together a little bag of nifty gifties for your son. That is so lovely, thank you. He's going to love it.
凯特，我们真的很高兴你今天能来。我们一直很兴奋，也非常感谢你将聚光灯投向办公室女士。谢谢。谢谢你今天的到来。我们一直很兴奋，也非常感谢你将聚光灯投向办公室女士。谢谢。谢谢你的支持。它给我们带来了许多欢乐，远超我们全家一起观看整部剧（所有九季）时所体验到的快乐，
Kate, we really are so excited that you're here today. We've been excited and we're just so grateful that you're gonna shine a light on office ladies. Thank you. Thank you for here today. We've been excited and we're just so grateful that you're gonna shine a light on Office Ladies. Thank you. Thank you for your service. It's provided us many hours of joy, well beyond the joy that our family experienced watching the whole show together, all nine seasons,
我们在去年某个时候看完了全剧，我想。然后我们就开始听播客来重温它。我喜欢这样。嗯，那一直是我们的目标。没错。这一直是我们的目标。好吧，当文章发表时，我们一定会分享。我们为什么不开始剖析这一集呢？
which we finished last year sometime, I think. So then we started listening to the podcast to relive it. I love that. Well, that's been our goal. That's right. This whole time. Well, when the article comes out, we'll be sure and share. And why don't we get down to breaking this episode down?
好的，吉姆和帕姆要来上班了，他们，我敢说，正处于幸福甜蜜的爱河中。他们在停车场这样小跑，我们已经很久没看到了。他们有一个超级可爱的联合谈话头（Talking Head）。随着最后几集的播出，我一直在指出所有的谈话头。而这个是面向外部的。
All right, Jim and Pam are gonna arrive to work and they are, dare I say, blissfully in love. This trot through the parking lot, we haven't seen this in a while. They have a super cute joint talking head together. I'm pointing out all the talking heads as these final episodes play out. And this one is facing out.
吉姆和帕姆面向着他们生活的未来。不过，也许他们应该面向内部，因为吉姆要回到邓德米夫林了。嗯。也许谈话头比他们此刻知道的更多。也许谈话头的编剧知道得更多。嗯-hmm。吉姆将分享他正在从“绝胜体育”请假，费城的家伙们一直在不停地打电话，但最重要的是他们两个在一起，他们度过了一些美好的日子，帕姆说还有
Jim and Pam are facing out to the future of their life. Although, maybe they should be facing in since Jim is coming back to Dunder Mifflin. Hmm. Maybe the talking head knows more than they do at this moment. Maybe the writer of the talking head knows more. Mm-hmm. Jim is going to share that he's taking time off from athlete and the guys in Philly have been calling non-stop but all that matters is the two of them being together and they've had some great days together and Pam says and a
一个美好的早晨。然后吉姆说：“比斯利。”嗯-hmm。我们在布鲁克林的Anto P那里收到一个粉丝提问，非常吸引我。Anto问，你们知道“帕姆幸运毛衣”这个理论吗？不，我不知道。谢恩的是，Anto附上了这个理论的链接。这个理论是说帕姆有一件“约会毛衣”。不会吧！是的，这是一件粉红色的开衫，显然如果她穿了它，
nice morning too. And then Jim's like Beasley. Mm-hmm. Well we had a fan question from Anto P in Brooklyn that so intrigued me. Anto said are you aware of the quote Pam lucky sweater theory? No, I was not. Thankfully, Anto linked to this theory. The theory is that Pam has a sex sweater. No! Yes, it is a pink cardigan, and apparently if she wears it,
就意味着吉姆和帕姆最近刚做过爱。开玩笑吧。是的。你有没有回去翻看以前的剧集？有。所以，在《地毯》那一集里，她刚从波科诺山和罗伊度假回来，当迈克尔问她有没有走运时，她犹豫着回答。她穿了那件粉色毛衣吗？她穿了。别闹了。
it means that Jim and Pam have recently had sex. Get out. Yes. Did you like go back and look at episodes? Yes. So in the carpet, she's just returned from the Poconos with Roy, and she hesitates to answer
后来她不得不告诉吉姆，哦，嗯，我们没怎么滑雪。就像她很害羞一样，好像在说，不，我们其实没怎么滑雪。所以，好吧。然后我猜她在《PDA》里又穿了一次。那是她和吉姆在储藏室里亲热的那一集。对。然后她在这一集里也穿了。现在，她还有一次穿过。她在《顾客忠诚度》里穿过，那是西西举办独奏会
when Michael asks if she got lucky. Is she wearing the pink sweater? She is. Stop. And later she has to tell Jim like, oh, well we didn't ski much. Like she's all like shy to be like, no,, we didn't ski much. Like, she's all shy to be like, no, we actually didn't ski much.
而她崩溃大哭的那一集。所以。也许那一次稍微打破了这个理论。确实打破了，但人们不总是说，哦，那是证明规则的例外吗？难道没有这种说法吗？为了证明一条规则，总会有一个例外。那句话是什么意思？
So, OK. Then I guess she wears it again in PDA. That's the episode where her and Jim hook up in the closet. Right. And then she wears it in this episode, too. Now, she wore it one other time. She wore it in customer loyalty, and that's the one where Cece has her recital
说实话。我们不知道，我们为什么要在问对方这个问题？我们不知道它是什么意思。但无论如何，粉丝们想知道这是否是对她最后将与布赖恩分享的那个私密时刻的呼应，即那里仍然存在亲密感，尽管不是肉体上的亲密感。粉丝们是这样为之辩解的。
and she breaks down crying. So. Maybe that one throws the theory off a little. It does, but don't they always say, oh, that's the exception that proves the rule? Isn't that that saying? In order to prove a rule, there's always one exception. Is that what that sentence means?
我的意思是，关于剧集的各个部分，外面有很多各种各样的理论。粉丝们是这样为之辩解的。我的意思是，关于剧集的各个部分，外面有很多各种各样的理论。这个对我来说是最令人惊讶的。她有一件“我走运了”的毛衣？哦，天哪。这是一个过于私人的问题。你有没有一件衣服可能会暗示别人
I'm gonna be honest with you. We don't know, why are we asking each other this? We don't know what it means. But anyway, fans wondered if maybe that was a nod to the private moment that she's gonna share with Brian in the end, that there was still intimacy, even though it wasn't sexual intimacy. This is how the fans justified it.
你刚刚走运了的事实？看看我。什么？看看我今天是怎麽走进来的。好吧，我想也许你今天早上没走运。但如果你走运了，你可能会穿什么？谁带着三个去学校的送学任务还能走运？谁有那个时间？
I mean, there are a lot of theories out there about different parts of the show. the fans justified it. I mean, there are a lot of theories out there about different parts of the show. This one is the most surprising to me. That she's got a, I got lucky sweater? Oh my gosh. This is a way too personal question. Do you have an item of clothing that might tip someone off
我不是在问那个。我只是在问。让我告诉你。我告诉你，如果你在下午2点30分看到我穿着睡裤，那可能是因为我享受了下午的欢愉。我只想说这些。如果我在下午2点30分之前穿上了睡裤，那是因为我们进行了一些亲热，
to the fact that you just got lucky? Look at me. What? Look how I rolled in here today. Well, I'm thinking maybe you didn't get lucky this morning. But if you had gotten lucky, what might you be wearing? Who can't get lucky with three kids at school drop off? Who has the time?
我洗了个澡，然后我想，好吧，我这个时间就不换衣服了。我干脆穿上睡裤，从下午一直晃悠到睡觉时间。这就是你的暗示。如果你下午2点30分顺道来我家，而我穿着睡裤，那可能就是一个很好的信号。我们现在都知道了。我想对我来说，如果我顶着湿漉漉的头发出现的话。
That's not what I'm asking. I'm just asking. Let me tell you. I'll tell you, if you see me in pajama bottoms at 2.30 in the afternoon, it's because maybe I had some afternoon delight. That's all I'm saying. If I've put my pajama bottoms on by 2.30, it's because we had some hanky panky,
哦。哦。我觉得我经常看到那样！好吧。因为我时间不够用了。哦！我刚刚有了一个顿悟。另外，我刚才突然意识到：我们的孩子绝对不能听这一集。不，他们绝对不能。不，他们绝对不能。
I took a shower, and I was like, well, I'm not gonna get dressed at this point. I'll just put my pajama bottoms on and I'll roll through the afternoon into bedtime. That's your tell. If you stop by my house at 2.30 and I have pajama bottoms on, that might be a good one. We all know now. I guess for me, it'd be like if I show up with wet hair.
好啦。好啦。嗯，关于“证明规则的存在”这个短语，是的，好吧。所以你要告诉我们它是什么意思吗？该论点指出，如果一个例外存在或必须被说明，那么这个例外就证明了必定存在某种规则，在这种情况下，例外就是……所以这句话是：“特准男士们今晚可以在晚上11点前离开军营。”
Oh. Oh. I feel like I've seen that a lot! Okay. Because I have run out of time. Oh! I have just gained an insight. Also, I just had this moment of like, our kids cannot listen to this episode. No, they cannot. No, they cannot.
“特准男士们今晚可以在晚上11点前离开军营。”这句话的“例外证明规则”意味着，这种特许意味着存在一条规定，要求男士们
Yeah. All right. All right. Well, hmm the phrase proving the existence of the rule Yeah, okay So are you gonna tell us what it means? The argument states that if an exception exists or has to be stated then this exception proves that there must be some rule In which case is the exception so the phrase Special leave is given for men to be out of the barracks tonight until 11 p.m phrase, special leave is given for men to be out of the barracks tonight until 11 p.m. The exception proves the rule means that this special leave implies a ruling requiring men
除非有此例外，否则必须更早回营。这种解释法规的价值是不言而喻的。好吧，你刚才说服了我，现在又把我弄糊涂了。但我要回到你刚才说服我的那个时刻，我觉得我懂了。我觉得我们必须说存在一个例外，这本身就证明了这条规则一开始就是存在的。完全正确。所以如果商店里有一个牌子写着“冰箱需要预付配送费”，其隐含意义就是其他物品不需要预付配送费。
except when the exception is made to be an earlier. The value of this interpreting statutes is plain. Okay, you had me, you lost me. But I'm going to go back to when you had me and I think I get it. I think the fact that we have to say there's an exception to this rule proves that a rule exists in the first place. Exactly. So if there's a sign in a shop that said, pre-paid delivery required for refrigerators, would be that pre-paid delivery is not required for other objects.
对。这就是规则的例外。你知道我脑子里现在在想什么吗？就像如果你从波士顿坐A线火车并在2点出发，就是那种数学应用题。你们什么时候在俄亥俄州碰头？我不知道，我不知道。你不知道。我不想去想它。好吧，听着，我们讲到哪儿了？哦，安迪正要在茶水间接近吉姆，征求他对领带的意见。
Right. That's the exception to the rule. You know what is happening in my brain right now? It's like if you take the A train from Boston and you leave at 2 o'clock, it's that problem, it's that math problem. When do you meet? When do you meet up if you meet in Ohio? I don't know, I don't know. You don't know. I don't want to figure it out. Alright well listen, where are we? Oh well Andy is about to approach Jim in the break room to ask his opinion on ties.
他说：“哪条领带让我看起来像个喜欢沙发的人？”他的经纪人正帮他争取一个家具广告。好吧，吉姆说绝对是蓝色领带。然后我们得知吉姆可能有一个新绰号。不再是大金枪鱼了，而是“生鱼片”。因为他把自己分身得太薄了。切成薄片的金枪鱼。嗯-hmm。我这里有几件事想指出来。
He says, which tie makes me look like a guy who likes sofas? His agent is putting him up for a furniture commercial. Well Jim says definitely the blue tie. And then we learn that Jim might have a new nickname. No longer Big Tuna, Carpaccio. Because he's been spreading himself too thin. Thinly sliced tuna. Mm-hmm. I have a few things here that I'd like to point out.
好的。我有粉丝发来的背景抓包。你想从哪儿开始？首先，我很高兴我们发现安迪有工作妆，为此有几个糖果袋的替代版本。真的吗？嗯-hmm，我要分享我最喜欢的那一个。
All right. I have a background catch from a fan. Where do you want to start? First of all, I love that we find out that Andy has work makeup, and there were a few candy bag alts for this. Really? Uh-huh, and I'm gonna share the one I love.
好吧。安迪说：“说得对，大金枪鱼。在这份工作和我的演艺事业之间，我感觉自己像是在过着双重生活。我现在甚至算是什么人？沙发买家二号还是安迪·伯纳德？我可说不准。”我喜欢这句台词。
Okay. Andy says, tell me about it, Big T. Between this job and my acting, it's like I've been living a double life. Like who even am I right now? Sofa buyer number two or Andy Bernard? I couldn't tell ya. I like that line.
然后我还有一个背景抓包。好吧，我想这就是我们俩今天为什么带了这些大箱子的原因。哦，好吧，是的。我的背景抓包来自田纳西州诺克斯维尔的Haley S.，她注意到吉姆身后茶水间的自动售货机里，有一包薯片，是烤猪肋排口味的。确实有。那是我的抓包。
And then I have a background catch. Well, I think it's why we both brought these big boxes today. Oh, well, yes. My background catch came from Haley S. in Knoxville, Tennessee, who noticed that in the vending machine in the break room behind Jim, there is a package of chips and they are flavored baby back rib chips. They are. That was my catch.
如果你去到A1槽位1分33秒处。这些真的是写着“烤猪肋排”的薯片吗？我必须知道，这真的是一种现实存在的薯片吗？我也是。然后我们俩都买了一箱。事情是这样的。它们只在某些地方有售，至少是区域性的，是Hers牌薯片。这是一种真实的薯片。
If you go to one minute, 33 seconds in the A1 slot. Are these chips that say baby back ribs? I had to know, is this a real chip? Same. And then we both bought boxes of them. Here's the thing. They only come, at least they're regional, they're hers chips. They're a real chip.
如果你去到A1档的1分33秒。这些是写着婴儿背肋骨的薯片吗？我必须知道，这是真的薯片吗？我也是。然后我们俩都买了几盒。事情是这样的。它们只在当地出售，至少是地区的，是赫尔兹薯片。它们是真的薯片。
And the only way we could get them here to the West Coast at least the only way I could find was by ordering a giant variety box of hers chips same so guess what you guys today everybody gets hers chip But we have to try Where is it? Where is it Jenna? We have to try the baby back ribs chips All right y'all in the sound booth you can have your own bag or share there are so many. Okay guys are you ready? Alright. Opening bag. Will these taste different than just barbecue chips is my big question. Here we go. Here we go. Oh my gosh they taste
而我们能把它们买到西海岸的唯一方法，至少我能找到的唯一方法，就是订购一大盒各种口味的赫尔斯薯片，没错，所以你们猜怎么着，大家今天都有赫尔斯薯片吃，但我们得尝尝，在哪儿呢？在哪儿呢，珍娜？我们得尝尝烤肋排味的薯片。好了，各位，声音控制室里的你们可以拿自己的一包，或者一起分享，这儿有好多呢。好了，各位，准备好了吗？好的。正在拆包装。它们尝起来会跟普通的烧烤味薯片有什么不同吗？这是我的重大疑问。我们开始吧。我们开始吧。噢天哪，它们尝起来
like ribs. They really do. Oh near the oh I kind of liked it and then I didn't. Oh my god I love them. What is they make me want to have ribs. What does everyone else think? I'm gonna eat another one. They're fine. Fine. It tastes like barbecue. I was worried they were gonna have meat in them. Oh no. But they don't. It says artificially flavored. Yeah. They're not bad but yeah there's like a lingering vinegar taste to it I think. Kate, did you try one? I like them quite a bit. I do too. I mean, I'm still eating them.
就像肋排。真的好像。哦，差点……哦，我刚开始觉得还行，后来又觉得不行了。哦天哪，我太喜欢了。这……它们让我想吃排骨了。其他人觉得怎么样？我要再吃一个。挺好的。挺好的。尝起来就像烧烤味。我之前还担心里面会有肉呢。哦，没有。但并没有。上面写着人工调味。对啊。它们不赖，不过，是的，我觉得回味里好像有一股挥之不去的醋味。凯特，你尝了吗？我很喜欢。我也是。我是说，我还在吃呢。
I was gonna say, Jennifer, someone who was like, I don't know how I feel about it, you just ate five. You just sit there quietly chomping on your chips. So sorry. Okay. All right. Well, was that worth us both purchasing and carrying these giant boxes to work today? I don't know.
我本来想说，珍妮弗，作为一个刚才还说“我不知道自己对这感觉如何”的人，你刚才已经连吃五个了。你就在那儿静静地嚼着薯片。真是不好意思。好吧。好了，那我们俩今天买下这些大盒子并搬到公司来，到底值不值得？我不知道。
Well, we're gonna have hers chips for a while here. We are. I'm excited because there's some sour cream and onion in the box, and I actually love hers sour cream and onion. You do. There's also, I just wanna say, something called jalapeno popper cheese curls, and Lee had a bag and said they're delicious.
好吧，接下来好一阵子我们都有赫尔斯薯片吃了。确实有。我很兴奋，因为盒子里有一些酸奶油洋葱味的，我其实超爱赫尔斯酸奶油洋葱味。你确实爱。我还想说的是，里面有一种叫墨西哥辣椒芝士卷的东西，李吃过一包，说它们可好吃了。
Oh, I'll be trying that after this. Okay. All right. Not sponsored by hers, I'll be trying that after this. Okay, all right. Not sponsored by hers, but maybe we should be. Someone write an email. Maybe we should let them know. I have to tell you that I found some amazing gems in my digital clutter.
哦，我等会儿要试试这个。好吧。好了。不是赫尔斯赞助的，我等会儿要试试这个。好吧，好了。不是赫尔斯赞助的，但也许我们应该拉赞助。谁去写封邮件吧。也许我们应该让他们知道。我得告诉你们，我在数字杂物里发现了一些惊人的宝贝。
Really? Yes, and I went old school, back to the days of when I used to do note cards, and I made two note cards, and Jenna, you get to pick which one I'll share first. I will share both of these digital clutter items in this episode, but these are your choices. Read them out loud.
真的吗？是的，而且我用了老办法，回到了我以前用便签卡的那些日子，我做了两张便签卡，珍娜，你来挑一下我想先分享哪一个。我会在这一集里分享这两件数字杂物，但这些由你来选。大声读出来吧。
Dorks in a trailer? Wedding bells. Aw. I'm going to choose dorks in a trailer, but I just, I got a little bit sentimental seeing you bring in these note cards that we, you know, we're getting near the end here of our re-watch, and I haven't seen a note card in a while, and it just made me sentimental.
房车里的怪咖们？婚礼的钟声。啊。我要选房车里的怪咖们，但我只是……看到你带这些我们……你知道的，我们重温节目快要接近尾声了，而我有一阵子没见到便签卡了，这让我有点多愁善感。
I know, I used to bring in like 45. You did. All right, tell me about Dorks in a Trailer. I will. One second while I find it. So I have been going back, you know, looking at each week we film an episode, I go into my email.
我知道，我以前会带大约45张来。你确实带过。好了，跟我讲讲“房车里的怪咖们”。我会的。等我找一下，一秒钟。所以我有回溯过，你知道的，看着我们拍摄每一周的剧集，我会翻看我的电子邮件。
As you know, I never delete emails, so I have a ton of old emails. And in one of my emails, I found a video that I made in your trailer at lunch about this episode. Oh my gosh, a video. A video. your trailer at lunch about this episode. Oh my gosh, a video. A video. So the week we did this episode, I guess I made a video maybe for NBC.com on my phone
如你所知，我从来不删邮件，所以我有一堆旧邮件。在我的其中一封邮件里，我发现了一段视频，那是午休时我在你的房车里拍的，关于这一集的。噢天哪，是一段视频。一段视频。在你的房车里关于这一集的午休视频。噢天哪，是一段视频。一段视频。所以就在我们拍这一集的那个星期，我想我可能在手机上为NBC.com拍了一段视频
and I still had it and wait till you see us lady, we are such dorks, but it made me so happy to see this. I'm so glad I still had this in my email. I'm gonna play it for you, but everyone out there can hear the audio, but you'll get to see the video and I'll also share it in our stories. Hi everybody, it's Angela Kinsey
我竟然还留着它，等你们看到我们俩，女士们，我们真是两个怪咖，但看到这个让我太开心了。我太高兴我的邮箱里还留着这个了。我要放给你们看，外面的每个人都能听到音频，但你们能看到视频，我也会把它分享到我们的快拍里。大家好，我是安吉拉·金西
from the set of The Office with Jenna Fisher. Hi! We just wanna let you guys know that there are two episodes of The Office airing tonight, brand new, one full hour. The first half hour is a lot of Dwight fun, wacky comedy. And the second one is one of my favorites of the year. Some big stuff for jam.
来自《办公室》剧组，与珍娜·费舍尔在一起。嗨！我们只想让你们知道，今晚《办公室》将连续播出两集，全新剧集，整整一小时。前半小时有很多德怀特式的搞笑、古怪的喜剧。后半小时是我这一年里最喜欢的剧集之一。贾姆（Jim和Pam）有些重大看点。
So check it out. Check it out people, check it out. Woo! This is, we are still the same. I know. Do you know when you see like videos of kids and then they're the same as an adult? We are still the same.
所以快去看吧。大家快去看，快去看。呜！这是……我们还是老样子。我知道。你知道吗，当你看到孩子们小时候的视频，然后他们长大了还是一模一样？我们还是一模一样。
I am just, I'm going to give you the information that NBC.com put in the memo that they asked us to relay and then you're like, whoop whoop. And I'm like, check it out. Yep. Aw, we're still going strong. We're still dorking it up. Okay. And then I will play wedding bell card later.
我简直……我要把NBC.com在备忘录里让我们转达的信息念给你听，然后你就“喔喔”，而我就说“快去看”。没错。啊，我们依然活力满满。我们依然在犯傻。好吧。然后我稍后会播放婚礼钟声的卡片。
I love it. Well, Angela is I will play wedding bell card later. I love it. Well, Angela is gonna arrive to the office now. She is disheveled. She looks miserable. I looked up in the shooting draft how it was described. Yes, I was gonna ask you. Here's what it says. Angela enters the office looking like a wreck.
太棒了。好了，安吉拉现在要来到办公室了。她衣衫不整。她看起来惨极了。我在拍摄剧本里查过它是怎么描述的。对，我正要问你呢。上面是这样写的：安吉拉走进办公室，看起来像个废人。
She's in jeans, an inside out sweater with the shoulder pads exposed and she sips from a big gulp cup. She looks like shit. That's what it said. I mean, Oscar is concerned. He asks if she's okay. This is when she tells him that the county took her cats.
她穿着牛仔裤，一件把垫肩露在外面、穿反了的毛衣，还正啜饮着一大杯巨无霸饮料。她看起来像坨屎。上面就是这么写的。我是说，奥斯卡很担心。他问她是不是还好。这就是她告诉他警察局把她的猫带走了的时候。
Yes, I do wanna point out, the moment I walk into the office, like sipping on that big gulp, that is one of my memes that I see in the world. I bet. And people usually post it and they write something like, heading into Monday, like dot, dot, dot. And then it's me sipping on a big gulp.
对，我确实想指出，我走进办公室的那一刻，啜饮着那个巨无霸饮料，那是我在网络上经常看到的表情包之一。我敢说。人们通常会发出来，然后写点类似于“迎接周一的心情，就像……”之类的话。然后就是我啜饮着巨无霸饮料的样子。
We did get a question about your hair. Oh, yeah. Martha B from Malta, we've heard from Martha before, on a big gulp. We did get a question about your hair. Oh yeah? Martha B from Malta, we've heard from Martha before, would like to know, did you have your hair back combed every day? That must have been hard to deal with. Martha, what Kim did is she had me turn my head upside down and then we just kind of shook it and teased it
我们确实收到了一个关于你头发的问题。噢，是的。来自马耳他的玛莎·B，我们以前听过玛莎的消息，关于巨无霸饮料。我们确实收到了一个关于你头发的问题。噢，是真的吗？来自马耳他的玛莎·B，我们以前听过玛莎的消息，她想知道，你的头发是不是每天都要倒梳？那一定很难打理吧。玛莎，金（Kim）的做法是让我把头倒过来，然后我们就把它抖一抖、倒梳一下
and then she sprayed it and had me flip back over, and then we crunched it and sprayed it again. You know, I was looking through old photos, and it's really not much different than how I used to do my hair in the 80s in Texas. It's kind of the same. I'm just missing the wall bangs. Right.
然后她喷上定型喷雾，让我再翻回来，接着我们把它抓蓬松，再喷一次。你知道的，我翻看旧照片时发现，这其实跟我80年代在德克萨斯州弄头发的方式没太大区别。基本上是一样的。我只是少了那种贴面齐刘海。没错。
I really felt for Angela when she told Oscar that they took her cats when she was out, because I really felt for Angela when she told Oscar that they took her cats when she was out. Because I really felt the violation of someone coming into your home and taking something precious to you, like your cats. Oscar kind of expresses some sympathy, but Angela is, she's not ready for sympathy, right? And then the scene ends with her kind of trying to brush all this cat hair off her sweater and then she sniffs it. Mm-hmm. Yeah. That was all scripted. It says Angela pulls out a slicker brush and combs lumps of cat hair off her sweater, forms it into a ball, and sniffs it
当安吉拉告诉奥斯卡在她外出时他们把她的猫带走时，我真的对安吉拉感同身受，因为我真的对安吉拉感同身受，当她告诉奥斯卡在她外出时他们把她的猫带走时。因为我真切地感受到了那种有人闯入你家中、带走对你弥足珍贵的东西（比如你的猫）的被侵犯感。奥斯卡表现出了一些同情，但安吉拉她还没准备好接受同情，对吧？然后场景以她试图拂去毛衣上的这些猫毛、接着闻了闻而结束。嗯哼。对。这些都是剧本写好的。上面写着：安吉拉掏出一把宠物刷，从毛衣上梳下一团团猫毛，把它揉成一个球，然后依依不舍地闻了闻。
wistfully. And here's the thing. I had a whole wardrobe fitting for this episode, right? And the sweater they gave me, it wasn't real cat hair. My memory is it was like this mohair kind of fluff, you know that mohair kind of stuff? But it did float up in the air around me, it's like got stuck in my lip gloss, like I was, there were a few times where I was like,
事情是这样的。我为这一集试过一整套服装，对吧？他们给我的那件毛衣，其实并不是真的猫毛。我的记忆中，那是一种马海毛之类的绒毛，你知道那种马海毛的东西吗？但它确实在我周围的空气中飘浮，粘在了我的唇彩上，就像我……有好几次我都觉得，
blah, blah, blah. And I just loved it. I loved everything about this look. You know, Alicia, our costume designer, was really thoughtful about it. I loved that my sweater actually didn't end up having shoulder pads, but we made sure it was inside out and it had those little ribbons
巴拉巴拉。我太喜欢了。我喜欢这个造型的方方面面。你知道的，我们的服装设计师艾莉西亚（Alicia）在这方面真的很用心。我喜欢我的毛衣最后其实没有垫肩，但我们确保它是穿反的，而且上面有那些
that you attached to the hanger. That was my favorite detail. Yeah, I love that. Was that those ribbons. Now, when I hanger. That was my favorite detail. I love that. Those ribbons. Now when I get something, I snip those out immediately. Those things drive me absolutely nuts. Does anyone actually use those? You know what?
用来挂在衣架上的小带子。那是的我最喜欢的细节。对，我喜欢那个。是那些带子。现在当我，衣架。那是我的最爱细节。我喜欢那个。那些带子。现在当我拿到什么衣服时，我会立刻把它们剪掉。那些东西简直把我逼疯了。真的有人会用那些东西吗？你知道吗？
I have one dress that's like the one shoulder. Do you know what I mean? Where it's useful. Where it's useful. Otherwise I cut them out. Or they just flop around and they poke out from your armpit whole thing. No.
我有一件单肩的裙子。你知道我的意思吗？就是那种派上用场的时候。派得上用场。除此之外我都把它们剪掉。不然它们就会晃来晃去，从你的胳肢窝里戳出来。不。
They drive me crazy. They drive me crazy. They drive me crazy. But I loved them as this detail on Angela's sweater. I do have a background catch at two minutes and 52 seconds. I'm calling it a full circle, full circle moment here. If you look at the glass partition between Angela and Kevin, you can see the back of the yellow Post-It note.
它们把我逼疯了。它们把我逼疯了。它们把我逼疯了。但我很喜欢它们作为安吉拉毛衣上的这个细节。我在两分五十二秒处有一个背景彩蛋。我在这里称之为一个完美的闭环，一个圆满的时刻。如果你看安吉拉和凯文之间的玻璃隔断，你能看到那张黄色便利贴的背面。
It's the one that I made in the pilot episode inviting everyone to Sprinkles birthday. As you guys know, I've shared when I gave it to Brian as Kevin, he taped it to the partition. It stayed there all nine years and you can see it in this shot. I love that. And then you got to take that when the show ended and it ended up in our book.
就是我在试播集里做的、邀请所有人参加小不点（Sprinkles）生日的那张。如你们所知，我分享过，当我把它给扮演凯文的布莱恩时，他把它粘在了隔断上。它在那里待了整整九年，你在这个镜头里能看到它。我太喜欢了。然后剧集结束时你把它拿走了，它最后还进了我们的书里。
It is. Brian saved it all that time. Well, now Dwight is going to arrive to work and he is going to call for everyone's attention because there are four new weapons in this office. It's his arms and his legs. My favorite line in this. It's a total throwaway line. it's my favorite line when he says, this morning after hours of combat with some of the city's best teenagers, I earned my black belt. That's right. He then has a talking head where he talks about how he had to part ways with
确实。布莱恩把那个一直保存了下来。好吧，现在德怀特要来上班了，他要引起大家的注意，因为办公室里有四件新武器。就是他的双臂和双腿。我这里最喜欢的一句台词。这完全是一句随口带过的台词。这是我最喜欢的台词，他说：“今天早上，在与该市几名最优秀的青少年进行数小时的格斗后，我获得了黑带。”没错。接着他有一个面对镜头的独白，谈到他不得不与
Sensei Ira and he found a new dojo and a new sensei, Sensei Billy, who felt he had more than enough training to take the test. Yes. Because as it turns out, most students don't spend 20 years and $150,000 to get a black belt. I have two things. I got so tickled in this. Okay.
埃拉师父（Sensei Ira）分道扬镳，并找到了一家新道场和一位新师父——比利师父（Sensei Billy），他认为德怀特有足够多的训练来参加考核。没错。因为事实证明，大多数学生不会花20年时间和15万美元来考取黑带。我有两件事。我在这一段里笑死我了。好吧。
At three minutes and 39 seconds, this might be the poofiest hair Dwight has ever had. It's still the zipper part, but it's so poofy. I took a screen grab. I was laughing so hard. And Rainn, I wanna apologize in advance for how this screen grab looks. It's just where your face stopped when I hit pause. Look at his hair.
在三分三十九秒处，这可能是德怀特有过的最蓬松的头发了。依然是那个拉链头发型，但它太蓬松了。我截了图。我笑得太厉害了。雷恩，我要提前为这张截图的效果道歉。这只是当我按下暂停时你脸停下的地方。看看他的头发。
It's very, very poopy. This is my favorite thing. I'm gonna set it as his picture in my contacts now. I will share that in stories. And then I was really curious about what it costs to get a black belt. Were you curious about this? I was really curious about what it costs to get a black belt. Were you curious about this? I was fascinated.
它非常非常蓬松。这是我最喜欢的事。我打算把它设为我通讯录里他的头像了。我会把它分享到快拍里。然后我真的很好奇考取黑带要花多少钱。你对这个好奇吗？我真的很好奇考取黑带要花多少钱。你对这个好奇吗？我当时太着迷了。
So I guess Dwight has spent $7,500 a year to get his black belt. Okay. Well, I texted my sister-in-law in Colorado because she's been taking martial arts for a very long time. And I said, is this anywhere in the ballpark of what you spend? And this is what she had to say. It varies widely based on discipline, but for Taekwondo, it's been about four years for me. For first degree, then each degree up
所以我想德怀特为了拿到黑带，每年花7500美元。好吧。我给我在科罗拉多州的嫂子发了短信，因为她练武术已经很长时间了。我对她说：“这大概在你花费的合理范围内吗？”她是这么说的。根据流派的不同，差异很大，但如果是跆拳道，对我来说大约是四年。从初段开始，然后之后的每一段
is at least that number of years spent at the prior belt rank. So two years minimum to second degree, three before third, et cetera. You're constantly working towards it. And then there's the cost of the gear and tournaments and all that other stuff. So you're looking at about 4K for two years of training.
至少要花费在前一个段位上花费的同样的年数。所以升二段至少两年，升三段前三年，等等。你一直在朝着它努力。然后还有装备、比赛和所有其他杂七杂八的东西的费用。所以两年的训练大概需要4000美元。
But would two years of training at 4K get you to black belt? Because there's a lot of belts. I don't know. So we have you mom detective. I'm mom detective. I missed one last question, which would be, do you have your black belt? Well, we may never know.
但是4000美元两年的训练能让你拿到黑带吗？因为有好多带位呢。我不知道。所以我们有了你——妈妈侦探。我是妈妈侦探。我漏掉了一个最后的问题，那就是：你有黑带吗？好吧，我们可能永远不会知道了。
We may never know. I mean, I could text her and ask her. But it's better this way. But maybe we leave it. We leave it like this. I just looked it up. According to the Karate grading system, the average time takes around five years.
我们可能永远不会知道了。我是说，我可以发短信问她。但这样更好。不过也许我们就不问了。我们就这样留着。我刚查了一下。根据空手道评分系统，平均时间大约需要五年。
So it takes five years. And if we use your sister-in-law's logic of about 4,000 per year, he should have been able to do this for 20 grand. Four thousand for two years. Oh, so 2,000 a year. Yeah. Also, I love the premise, this is how mom detectives end. You know, maybe we'll never know. Yeah, we'll never know.
所以需要五年。如果我们按照你嫂子的逻辑，大约每年4000美元，他本该花两万美元就能搞定。两年四千。哦，也就是每年2000。另外，我喜欢这个设定，这就是妈妈侦探的结局。你知道，也许我们永远不会知道了。对，我们永远不会知道了。
We'll never know, and it's okay. And we stopped investigating. Yeah, exactly. We've moved on. We lost interest, maybe we'll never know. Yeah, we'll never know. We'll never know and it's okay. And we stopped investigating. Yeah, exactly. We've moved on. We lost interest and we've moved on. Well, Dwight is gonna invite everyone to his black belt ceremony here in the office at lunch, lunch not provided.
我们永远不会知道了，这也没关系。然后我们停止了调查。没错，正好。我们已经向前看了。我们失去了兴趣，也许我们永远不会知道了。对，我们永远不会知道了。我们永远不会知道了，这也没关系。然后我们停止了调查。没错，正好。我们已经向前看了。我们失去了兴趣，然后我们向前看了。好吧，德怀特要在办公室的午休时间邀请所有人参加他的黑带授带仪式，不提供午餐。
I love that that's when Phyllis turned away. She's like, I'm out. By the way, I'm gonna point out early that when we do get to the scene where Dwight is doing his black belt ritual, Leslie, as Stanley, is eating at his desk. It is lunchtime. It is perfect. He did eat his lunch.
我喜欢菲莉丝在这个时候转过身去。她一副“我不干了”的样子。顺便说一句，我要提前指出的是，当我们拍到德怀特进行他的黑带仪式的场景时，扮演斯坦利的莱斯利（Leslie）正在他的办公桌前吃饭。那是午餐时间。太完美了。他真的吃他的午饭了。
You know when Jim shouts fireball and Dwight throws his briefcase? Yes. They purposely put me to the edge of Oscar's death so I wouldn't get hit with it. Very smart. You do not want to be anywhere near Rainn Wilson when he is throwing a prop. You do not? No. I have a background catch during this scene. I noticed there are two-frame certificates by front reception that I had never seen before. Maybe you guys caught them. Really? I zoomed in and they are for the speed dialing and memo sorting competition. It's been there a long time.
你知道当吉姆大喊“火球”而德怀特扔掉公文包的时候吗？对。他们故意把我安排在奥斯卡的办公桌边缘，这样我就不会被它击中了。非常明智。当雷恩·威尔逊在扔道具时，你绝对不想离他太近。你不想吗？不想。我在这一幕里也有一个背景彩蛋。我注意到前台附近有两个相框证书，我以前从来没见过。也许你们大家注意到了。真的吗？我放大看了看，它们是关于快速拨号和备忘录分类比赛的。它在那儿挂了很久了。
You saw it? Oh yeah. When? Oh, I mean a while ago. Okay, well. Seasons ago, I think. Erin came in fourth one year and then one year she won and got her picture.
你看到了？哦，是的。什么时候？哦，我是说好一阵子以前了。好吧，好吧。几个季度前吧，我想。艾琳有一年得了第四名，然后有一年她赢了，还得了个照片。
My question is who's in this competition? Who's she beating to win this? Yeah. Who's running it? Who's running it? Who's she competing against? Who's also speed dialing and doing memo sorting? This is a great question. Is it for the building? Is it a regional thing? Yeah. Anyway, does it come with a giant check? Probably not. Well, then it's not worth much, is it? I just want to know who's in it.
我的问题是，谁参加了这个比赛？她打败了谁才赢得这个的？对啊。谁在运营这个？谁在运营这个？她是在和谁竞争？还有谁在快速拨号和做备忘录分类？这是一个好问题。这是为了整栋大楼吗？这是一个地区性的比赛吗？对啊。不管怎样，这会带有一张巨额支票吗？可能没有。那它就不值多少钱，对吧？我只是想知道谁参加了。
I would have loved to seen a scene of it. Well, we may never know. I don't know what to tell you. David Wallace is going to arrive and he's going to ask Erin if Andy is in. Erin completely panics because she's been juggling Andy's audition arrive and he's gonna ask Erin if Andy is in. Erin completely panics because she's been juggling Andy's audition schedule and it's really hectic and she's having trouble managing his calendar.
我很想看一场有关它的戏。好吧，我们可能永远不会知道了。我不知道该对你说什么。大卫·华莱士（David Wallace）要来了，他要问艾琳安迪在不在。艾琳彻底慌了，因为她一直在应付安迪的试镜来了，他要问艾琳安迪在不在。艾琳彻底慌了，因为她一直在应付安迪的试镜日程，这真的太忙乱了，她正费力地管理他的日程表。
She's super relieved to see that Andy is actually in the office that day. And Andy greets David, he said, David Walrus in his natural habitat. David Wallace has a talking head where he explains the reason that he's here is to fire Andy. Yeah. It's just been too much. Too much? He wanted cheek implants and he wanted the company to pay for it.
看到安迪那天真的在办公室，她超级如释重负。安迪迎上去对大卫说：“大卫·海象（David Walrus）回到了他的自然栖息地。”大卫·华莱士有一个面对镜头的独白，解释了他来这里的理由是为了解雇安迪。对。真的是太过分了。过分？他想要做面颊植入手术，还想让公司为之买单。
Yeah, and apparently he also found out that he used company funds to buy a color printer to make headshots. Fan question from Jenna F in Los Angeles. Oh, Jenna F wrote in? She did. She noticed that in this very quick little moment, this little B-roll under David Wallace's talking head that we see a shot of Andy at this color printer. And he is holding his headshot composite. Yes.
对，而且显然他还发现安迪动用公司资金买了一台彩色打印机来印演员大头照。来自洛杉矶的珍娜·F的粉丝提问。哦，珍娜·F写信来了？她确实写了。她注意到在这个非常快的镜头里，在大卫·华莱士的独白下面的这个B卷（花絮画面）里，我们看到了安迪在这台彩色打印机旁的一个镜头。而他手里拿着他的演员组合大头照。对。
Jenna F said, this is my favorite comedic prop from the whole show. I literally spit out my coffee when I saw it. Please tell me everything about this prop. So, it's just brilliant. I mean, I truly did spit out my coffee when I saw it. I was taking a sip of coffee and I choked on it. It is so perfect to me. I reached out to Ed because I had to ask him about this. He clearly had to take all these pictures of all these different characters. Here's what Ed had to say. Hey Jenna, I saw your text. So I don't remember a lot of details about that composite
珍娜·F说，这是整部剧中我最喜欢的喜剧道具。我看到的时候简直笑喷了咖啡。请告诉我关于这个道具的一切。所以，这简直太绝了。我是说，我看到的时候真的把咖啡喷出来了。我当时正喝着咖啡，然后被呛到了。这对我来说太完美了。我联系了埃德（Ed），因为我必须问他关于这个的事。他显然得拍所有这些不同角色的照片。埃德是这么说的。嘿，珍娜，我看到你的短信了。所以我对那张组合
headshot, but I agree it is really damn funny. And I just remember we wanted to kind of, I don't know, nod to what it's like to be starting out as an actor and especially a comedy actor. And I don't know about you, but I definitely had a composite headshot like that with a bunch of different characters. When you're starting out, it's sort of what you think the casting business wants from you, which is like a lot of options and a lot of variety. And sometimes we try a little too hard when we put those headshots together.
大头照没有太多细节的记忆了，但我同意它确实TMD太搞笑了。我只记得我们当时想，怎么说呢，向作为一个刚起步的演员（尤其是喜剧演员）的感觉致敬。我不知道你怎么样，但我确实有过那样一张带有好几个不同角色的组合大头照。当你刚出道时，这有点像你认为选角行业希望从你身上得到的东西，也就是大量的选择和丰富的多样性。有时候我们在把这些大头照拼凑在一起时，确实有点用力过猛了。
I don't even know if young actors today even do headshots, that everything's so online these days, but it was definitely a fun nod. And I remember brainstorming like, well, okay, if we're doing a composite headshot, like, what are the different characters? And so we just tried to come up with a good variety. And of course, there's always like a nerd character, a jock. And, and then what else did we do in
我甚至不知道现在的年轻演员是否还拍大头照，现在一切都在网上进行了，但这绝对是一个有趣的致敬。我记得我们集思广益，比如，好吧，如果我们要做一张组合大头照，不同的角色都有哪些？所以我们只是试图想出各种各样的组合。当然，总会有一个书呆子角色、一个运动员。然后，还有我们在
that a judge? And then there's just like the cool guy right in the middle. So yeah, it's just a nod to classic, you know, actors starting out trying to get that headshot to get those parts. I guess that's what it is. I just love that. It is so true. We all did it. In honor of Andy's composite headshots, I went through my drawer and I have brought in my first headshots.
那个里面加了什么？一个法官？然后正中间还有一个酷哥。所以，是的，这只是对经典的老派演员、刚出道时试图通过大头照来争取角色的致敬。我想就是这样。我太喜欢了。这太真实了。我们都这么做过。为了向安迪的组合大头照致敬，我翻了翻抽屉，把我最初的演员大头照带来了。
And then Jenna told me to do the same. So we're gonna have a show and tell. We are. So my very first headshot was, Cassie has stood up to see this. People are standing up. Okay. Okay.
然后珍娜叫我也这么做。所以我们要来个物件展示。我们会的。所以我的第一张大头照是……卡西（Cassie）站起来看这个了。大家都在站起来。好吧。好吧。
I mean, I have a stack. I only brought two. Did you bring them all? are standing up, okay. Okay. I mean, I have a stack. I only brought two. Did you bring them all? No, I brought three. Okay. My very first headshot, which I did not bring, was actually taken by my tech theater teacher in college. His name is Ron Rybkowski.
我是说，我有一叠。我只带了两张。你们都带来了吗？都在站起来，好吧。好吧。我是说，我有一叠。我只带了两张。你们都带来了吗？没有，我带了三张。好吧。我的第一张大头照，我没带过来，其实是我大学里的技术戏剧老师帮我拍的。他叫罗恩·雷布科夫斯基（Ron Rybkowski）。
I love this man. And something he did for any actor who needed it is he brought his camera in and he set up, you know, a backdrop and he took a picture for each of us when we graduated for free so that we would have something when we went out to become actors. It was a great picture. It got me in the door a lot of places. But of course, I get to LA and I get in my head about it and I think I need to hire one
我爱死这个人了。他为任何需要的演员做的一件事就是，他把相机带到学校，搭起一个背景板，在我们毕业时免费为我们每个人拍了一张照片，这样当我们出去当演员时就能有点东西。那是一张很棒的照片。它让我在很多地方敲开了门。但当然，我到了洛杉矶，开始胡思乱想，觉得我需要雇一个
of these LA headshot photographers to take my picture. The big thing you ask yourself is, what do I wear in this headshot? What do I wear? The advice I got was just wear something you're comfortable in, something that you're gonna be able to be yourself in. So I wore my favorite outfit,
洛杉矶的专业大头照摄影师来给我拍照。你问自己的核心问题是：我在这张大头照里该穿什么？我该穿什么？我得到的建议是：就穿让你觉得舒服的衣服，能让你做回自己的衣服。所以我穿了我最喜欢的行头，
which was at the time, pair of brown corduroy overalls and Doc Martens and here is my first Los Angeles headshot. How cute are you? You're so cute. Okay this headshot is super cute but it didn't help me get many auditions. Okay. I got some notes from agents saying you're kind of sitting in kind of a closed off way you're kind of hugging your knees. Let's try to be maybe more open. Why don't you try again?
当时是一条棕色的灯芯绒背带裤和马丁靴，这就是我的第一张洛杉矶演员大头照。你有多可爱？你太可爱了。好吧，这张大头照超级可爱，但它并没有帮我拿到多少试镜机会。好吧。我收到了一些经纪人的反馈，说你坐的姿势有点过于封闭了，你有点抱着膝盖。让我们试着开放一点。你为什么不重试一次呢？
So my hair had grown out a little bit, it was a little longer. So I hired a new photographer and I thought let's do this again. Okay. You might ask yourself. Did you change your outfit? Did not.
所以我的头发稍微留长了一点，稍微长了一点。所以我雇了一个新摄影师，我想让我们再来一次。好吧。你们可能会问自己。你换衣服了吗？没有换。
Did not sit in a less closed off way. You're doing the same pose basically. Same pose, same outfit, slightly longer hair. That's all that's happened. Yeah. That's it. I was like I'm gonna get this right. I cut my hair again and I was like I'm not gonna make this mistake again. Yeah. Third session didn't end up using this one but did have it blown up into an 8 by 10. Why? Why am I sitting on a stool like this? It's so weird. It's so awkward. Why is my zip down sweater tucked into my jeans? I don't know.
也没有以不那么封闭的姿势坐着。你基本上摆的是同一个姿势。同样的姿势，同样的衣服，稍微长一点的头发。这就是发生的一切。 yeah。就是这样。当时我想：我这次一定能弄对。我又把头发剪短了，然后我想：我绝不会再犯这个错误了。嗯。第三次拍摄最后没用这张，但把它放大成了8乘10英寸的照片。为什么？我为什么会像这样坐在高脚凳上？太诡异了。太尴尬了。为什么我把拉链毛衣塞进牛仔裤里了？我不知道。
What's happening? With a belt. She took a hoodie, a zipper sweater, she tucked it in jeans with a belt, and then straddled a stool. It's so awkward. It's awful. I have so many awkward ones too.
这到底是怎么回事？还系着皮带。她拿了一件连帽衫、一件拉链毛衣，把它塞进系着皮带的牛仔裤里，然后跨坐在高脚凳上。太尴尬了。糟透了。我也有好多尴尬的照片。
There are many more before I got it right. And I actually have a whole chapter about it in my book, The Actor's Life, and you can see them all. But I'll share these online. Okay. Well, because... But it got worse before it got better. Same here.
在我拍对之前，还有更多呢。事实上，我的书《演员的生活》里专门有一整章讲这个，你们可以看到所有的照片。不过我会把这些分享到网上。好吧。因为……但在变好之前，情况变得更糟了。我也是。
Because you told me you were bringing yours in, I was like, okay. I was in New York in my early 20s. This is when I was interning on the Conan O'Brien show and I was taking acting classes and I was going to move to LA and one of the gals was like you have to have a headshot if you're moving to Los Angeles. That's right. I was like okay. So I was like what do I wear and she said I would wear something denim. Oh no. What is wrong with us? What did you wear? She was like do you have a denim vest? No, she didn't. And I was like, I do.
因为你告诉我你要把你的带来，我就想，好吧。我20出头的时候在纽约。那正是我在柯南·奥布莱恩（Conan O'Brien）节目组实习、上表演课、准备搬去洛杉矶的时候，其中一个女孩说：“如果你要搬去洛杉矶，你必须有一张大头照。”没错。我就想：好吧。所以我就想：我穿什么呢？她说我应该穿件牛仔的。哦，不。我们脑子有什么毛病？你穿了什么？她说：“你有牛仔马甲吗？”不，她没有。然后我说：
I do actually. She goes, well, denim vest or a denim jacket. I didn't have a denim jacket. This is peak 90s guys. Then the photographer, I think just zoomed in, it's like neck up. This is my first headshot. Oh, you look cute.
我还真有。她接着说：“好吧，要不牛仔马甲，要不牛仔外套。”我当时没有牛仔外套。这可是90年代的巅峰时期啊，各位。然后摄影师，我觉得只是拉近了镜头，变成了大头照。这是我的第一张大头照。哦，你看起来好可爱。
And it doesn't look like a vest. It looks like a denim shirt. OK. Then, this is in New York. Then I move to Los Angeles. And I'm like, they're all like, well, you've got to get a real more body headshot, right? Not just your head.
它看起来不像是马甲。看起来像件牛仔衬衫。好的。然后，这是在纽约。然后我搬到了洛杉矶。然后我就想，大家都说：“好吧，你得拍一张更多半身的大头照，对吧？不只是头部。”
You need like 3 quarter, right? Yeah, that was the thing. That was the big thing. You were supposed to have like a headshot and a three quarter shot. Right, so I was like, okay, let's do this again. Did I try a new outfit? Did you? No.
你需要3/4身照，对吧？对，那是必须的。那是大趋势。你得有一张大头照和一张3/4身照。对，所以我就想：好吧，我们再来一次。我换了一套新衣服吗？你换了吗？没有。
What is wrong with us? I wore the denim vest again. Oh, I cut my hair. This is funny. Lady, I did not know this about you. Two photo shoots in the same denim vest. What is happening? This is the most, look how uncomfortable I look.
我们脑子到底有什么毛病？我又穿了那件牛仔马甲。哦，我把头发剪短了。这太搞笑了。天哪，我以前真不知道你这事。两次写真穿的都是同一件牛仔马甲。这到底是怎么回事？这简直是……看我看起来多不自在。
I'm like. Your thumbs are in your pocket. What is happening? And we wonder why it took us so long. To make it. Okay, we will share those in stories because they're special. All right. All right. Corduroy overall didn't invest.
我摆出……你的大拇指插在口袋里。这到底是怎么回事？难怪我们花了这么久才成功。好吧，我们会把这些分享到快拍里，因为它们很特别。好吧。好吧。灯芯绒背带裤和牛仔马甲。
Let's go! We were meant to be besties. We were. That is clear. Well, Andy is in his meeting with David Wallace, and David is about to launch into his sort of why I have to fire you speech, but Andy stops him. He's like, I need to stop you. Yeah, let me interrupt you right there.
走起！我们注定是要做闺蜜的。我们确实是。显而易见。好吧，安迪正在和大卫·华莱士开会，大卫正要开始他那套“我为什么不得不解雇你”的演讲，但安迪打断了他。他说：“我得打断你一下。”对，就在那儿打断我。
Every minute that I spend here is time not spent making audition videos for reality dating, cooking, or singing shows. I got a real shot here. David is like, wait, are you you you're saying that this job is like taking your focus away? You feel like you're you're too focused on this job. And Andy's like, yeah, he was so distracted at his last headshot session because he was wondering what he was missing at work. Turns out Andy is going to quit Dunder Mifflin because, quote, I am pursuing fame of any kind.
我在这里度过的每一分钟，都是没有用来为现实约会、烹饪或唱歌节目制作试镜视频的时间。我在这里可是有个好机会的。大卫觉得：等等，你是说……你是说这份工作分散了你的注意力？你觉得你太专注于这份工作了？安迪却说：对啊。他在上一次大头照拍摄时就一直心不在神往，因为他一直在想自己错过了多少工作。结果安迪要辞去邓德米夫林的工作，因为，引述他的话说：“我在追求任何形式的名气。”
Yeah, he said he owes it to himself and his future fans. Yeah, with this documentary about to air, this is the time, basically. So David is relieved. He's like, yeah, that worked out. And then Creed says, you know what, pretty much anyone can be a star, the Postman, the Night Janitor at the office,
对，他说他亏欠了自己和未来的粉丝。对，随着这部纪录片即将播出，现在就是时机，基本上是这样。所以大卫如释重负。他想：好吧，这倒挺顺利。然后柯里德（Creed）说：“你知道吗，差不多任何人都能成为明星，邮递员、办公室的夜间清洁工，但安迪不行，他是个魅力黑洞。”对。好吧，吉姆现在要走向克拉克（Clark），他要请克拉克把办公桌还给他，拜托。但克拉克觉得也许这是他应得的，也许吉姆应该坐在附属办公室（annex）里。我真的很喜欢吉姆说：“我回来的全部原因是为了和我妻子在一起，”而克拉克却说：
but Andy, no, charisma black hole. Yeah. Well, Jim is going to approach Clark now, and he's gonna ask for his desk back, please. But Clark feels like maybe he's earned it, and maybe Jim should sit in the annex. I did love when Jim's like, well, the whole reason I'm back is to be with my wife, and Clark goes,
“我是来卖纸的，”然后他敲了敲他的桌子。我太喜欢这个了。这就是我回来……为了和你妻子在一起。而克拉克说：“我是来卖纸的。”然后他敲了敲他的桌子。这就是我来这儿的目的。这台词太棒了。你知道，来自阿肯色州史密斯堡的娜塔莉·C（Natalie C.）非常喜欢这句台词，因为克拉克在台词“I'm here to sell paper”中那个非常重、非常具有阿肯色州特色的R音。娜塔莉接着说：“我喜欢捕捉你们所有的口音，听到一个如此具有我家乡特色的口音，让我更加喜欢这个场景了。”好吧，你知道克拉克在阿肯色州出生并长大，
I'm here to sell paper, and he taps his desk. I loved that. That's what I'm back is to, you know, be with my wife. And Clark goes, I'm here to sell paper. And he like taps his desk. That's what I'm here for. That was such a great line. You know, Natalie C. from Fort Smith, Arkansas loved that line because of Clark's very hard, very Arkansan R in the line, I'm here to sell paper. Natalie went on to say, I love being able to catch all of your accents and to hear one that is so clearly from my own home just makes me love the scene so much more. Well, you know Clark was born and raised in Arkansas
我有一段音频剪辑。娜塔莉，给你听这个。克拉克，我其实今天来了。真意外，所以我想知道我能不能把我的桌子要回来？好。是啊，你知道的，其实我最近每天都在这儿努力工作，所以我觉得我有点配得上这张桌子了。
and I have an audio clip. Natalie, here you go. Clark, I'm actually here today. Surprise, so I was wondering maybe I could have my desk back. Right. Yeah, but you know I've actually been working pretty hard here on a daily basis so I kind of feel like I've earned this.
我是说，你知道的？完全配得上。你是凭实力得到的。但也许我能和我妻子在一起。这基本上就是我来这里的全部原因。对。好吧，我是来卖纸的。就是这样。纸。纸。我是来卖纸的。我喜欢克拉克。我们刚才还在发邮件呢。他得来做客。他非常兴奋。哦，是的。是啊。你知道
I mean, you know? Totally have. You have earned it. But maybe I could be with my wife. That's kind of the whole reason why I'm here. Right. Well, I'm here to sell paper. There it is. Paper. Paper. I'm here to sell paper. I love Clark. We were just emailing. He's got to come on. He's very excited. Oh yeah. Yeah. You know
英斯利（Ainsley）认识克拉克。我知道。世界真小。我知道。他要来。好吧，我们为什么不休息一下，等我们回来后，我会分享我的“婚礼钟声”便签卡。安迪要在办公区（bullpen）发表一个重大宣布。我喜欢。米勒淡啤（Miller Lite），为热爱啤酒口感的人们酿造的淡啤，是你比赛时光的完美绝配。当米勒淡啤着手酿造一款淡啤时，他们必须在绝佳口感或每罐90
Ainsley knows Clark. I know. So small world. I know. He's coming on. Well why don't we take a break and when we come back I will share my wedding bells note card. And Andy's going to have a big announcement to the bullpen. I like it. Miller Lite, the light beer brewed for people who love the taste of beer and the perfect pairing for your game time. When Miller Light set out to brew a Light beer, they had to choose great taste or 90
卡路里之间做出选择。他们两样都选了，因为他们知道啤酒最棒的部分就是啤酒本身。你的比赛时光尝起来就像米勒时光。请登录 MillerLight.ca 了解更多信息。须达到法定饮酒年龄。你是戴夫吗，一个零理赔经验、拥有混合动力车的大学毕业生，并且是在网上注册的？那么戴夫，这个旋律就是为你而奏的。不是戴夫也没关系。道明保险（TD Insurance）有30多种方法帮你在房屋和汽车保险上省钱。所以。
calories per can. They chose both because they knew the best part of beer is the beer. Your game time tastes like Miller time. Learn more at MillerLight.ca. Must be legal drinking age. Are you Dave, a claims-free hybrid driving university grad who signed up online? Well Dave, this jingles for you. Not Dave, no problem. TD Insurance has over 30 ways to save on home and auto. So.
你完全可以省钱，只是方式可能不像戴夫那样。用只有你能用的方式省钱，尽在 tdinsurance.com 斜杠 ways to save。道明，随时准备为您服务。我们回来了，我有一张给你的便签卡，标题是《婚礼钟声》。这是因为在我们拍摄这一集时，我们举办了一场惊喜的婚前单身派对（bridal shower）。这就是我找到的那封邮件，然后史蒂夫·伯吉斯（Steve Burgess）还发给我了单身派对的照片。上面写着：你好，办公室的朋友们，正如你们许多人所知，
You can totally save, just not exactly like Dave. Save like only you can at tdinsurance.com slash ways to save. TD, ready for you. We are back and I have a note card for you titled Wedding Bells. It is because while we were filming this episode we threw a surprise bridal shower. This was the email I found and then Steve Burgess also sent me pictures from the bridal shower. It said, Hello Office Friends, as many of you know,
我们的第一助理导演凯莉·坎特利（Kelly Cantley）找到了她的伴侣并即将结婚。我们将在午餐时在餐饮桌旁为她举办一场惊喜的婚前单身派对。请帮我们保守这个秘密。我们邀请大家一起来吃蛋糕和气泡苹果酒，任何想带礼物的人都可以把它放在制作办公室里。
our first AD, Kelly Cantley, has met her mate and is getting married. We will be throwing her a surprise bridal shower at the catering tables during lunch. Please help us keep this a secret. We invite everyone to come for cake and sparkling cider, and anyone who wishes to bring a gift may drop it off at the production office.
以下是她的礼品登记处。如有任何问题，请发邮件给安吉拉或斯蒂芬妮，我们到时见。太贴心了。太贴心了。嗯哼。我就是喜欢我们曾是一个大家庭。这就是为什么我们至今仍保持联系，我也喜欢找到这样的小邮件。我希望你们会喜欢听这个，因为这确实是一群特别特别的人。真的是这样。好吧，接下来，安迪要在办公区发表一个非常重大的宣布。他将向邓德米夫林请无限期的假。对。每个人都以为他被解雇了。他说：“不，不，不，不，不。这是我主动选择的。我要离开是因为我要去追求我的梦想。”对，他说，红毯上见。
And here are her registries. Please email Angela or Steph with any questions and we'll see you there. Sweetest thing. So sweet. Mm-hmm. I just love that we were a family. That's why we're all still in touch and I love finding little emails like this. I hope you guys like hearing it because it really was a special, special group of people. It really was. Well next up, Andy is going to make a very big announcement to the bullpen. He is taking a lifetime leave of absence from Dunder Mifflin. Yeah. Everyone assumes he's been fired. He's like, no, no, no, no, no. I've chosen this. I'm leaving because he is going to pursue his dreams. Yeah, he said, see you on the red carpet.
然后大家都觉得：哦，安迪。对。菲莉丝有一个面对镜头的独白。她说：“安迪唱歌很好听。而且你知道的，他很擅长跳舞和演讲，但有些地方，你就是没法直视。”对。她的独白是朝向外面的。
And everybody is like, oh, Andy. Yeah. Phyllis has a talking head. She says, Andy sings beautifully. And you know, he's good at dancing and speaking, but there's something there you just don't wanna look at. Yeah. Her talking head is facing out.
哦。现在我们前往附属办公室。吉姆和皮特正在工作，他们有点像是在努力成为哥们儿。他们试图进行那种直男式的兄弟情 bonding（建立连结）。对，吉姆说：“我打赌你有点想念克拉克吧，嗯？”皮特说：“对啊。”我是说，皮特
Oh. Now we're headed to the annex. Jim and Pete are working and they're kind of like trying to be buddies. They're trying to like dude bro bond. Yeah, Jim's like, I bet you kind of miss Clark, huh? And Pete's like, yeah. I mean, Pete.
太诚实了。他确实是。然后吉姆说：“费城人队加油（Go Phillies）！”皮特说：“不。”我是说，皮特太诚实了。他确实是。然后吉姆说：“费城人队加油！”皮特说：“不。”这不可能发生。他不看棒球。这两个“吉姆”是建立不了兄弟情深的。然后我喜欢，显然，但我喜欢
Is so honest. He is. And then Jim's like, go Phillies. And Pete's like, no. I mean, Pete is so honest. He is. And then Jim's like, go Phillies. And Pete's like, no. It's not happening. He doesn't watch baseball. The two Jims are not going to bond. And then I love, clearly, but I love
托比（Toby）不得不再次经历这个时刻。他确实如此。他总是出现在所有人谈话的背景里。接下来，达里尔（Darrell）要走进安迪的办公室，真心试图点醒他，但安迪误解了这一点。对，达里尔有这一集里我最喜欢的台词之一。他说：“听着，假设你找到了一份工作（你可能找不到）。他们不会给你任何喘息空间的，而你天生就适合一份有大量大量喘息空间的工作。”对。难道不是
that Toby, once again, has to live through this moment. He does. He's always in the background of all these people's conversations. Next up, Darrell is going to go into Andy's office and really try to talk some sense into him, but Andy misinterprets this. Yeah, Darryl has one of my favorite lines of the episode. He said, listen, let's say you get a job which you probably won't. They're not gonna cut you any slack and you're meant for a job with lots and lots of slack. Yeah. Isn't that
那个我们曾经读到过的那个原则吗？彼得原理？对。感觉就像那些需要有很多喘息空间的工作的人。没错。安迪当然认为这是达里尔向他道别的方式，对吧？他说：“男人是一个有趣的物种。我们不会直接告诉彼此我们的感受，那是娘娘腔的东西。所以与其说‘嘿，安迪，我爱你，兄弟，我不想让你走’，你却会说‘嘿，安迪，你正在犯你一生中最大的错误’。”
that principle that we read about that one time the Peter principle? Yeah. That feels like people who need a job with a lot of slack. That's right. Andy of course thinks this is Daryl's way of saying goodbye, right? He says the male is a funny species. We don't just tell each other how we feel, that's chick stuff. So instead of saying, hey Andy, I love you man, I don't want you to leave, you say something like, hey Andy, you're making the worst mistake of your life.
“你根本没有天赋。”好吧，彼此彼此，达里尔。他就像是：彼此彼此，达里尔。好样的，兄弟。好样的。所以安迪给了达里尔一个大大的拥抱，并说：“我也将错过你。”现在我们要听听办公室里其他一些人的看法。
You're not talented. Well, right back at you, Darryl. He's like, right back at you, Darryl. Yeah, buddy. Yeah. So Andy gives Darryl a big hug and says, I'm going to miss you too. Now we're going to hear from some other folks in the office.
他们要告诉我们他们对安迪的伟大梦想有何感受，首先是斯坦利。他说：“闭嘴干活、然后安安静静因为心脏病发而死的那一代人去哪儿了？”他受够了安迪这一代人，他们认为自己都应该成名。斯坦利会对TikTok作何感想？哦，不。
They're going to tell us how they feel about Andy's big dreams, starting with Stanley. He says, what happened to the generation of shut up and do your work and die quietly from a heart attack? He's over Andy's generation, who thinks they all should be famous. What would Stanley think of TikTok? Oh, no.
他是绝对不会接受的。那绝对是不行的。尤其是因为你知道迈克尔肯定会一直在玩那个。哦，是的。你知道我们在迈克尔手下都学了多少TikTok舞蹈吗？噢天哪。
He would not be having it. That would be a no. Especially because you know it's all Michael would be doing. Oh yeah. Do you know how many TikTok dances we've all learned under Michael? Oh my gosh.
太多了。太多了。迈克尔·斯科特会带着整个办公区一起跳某种TikTok舞蹈。你知道的，我在空闲时间会学TikTok舞蹈，但我从来不发自己跳的视频。我知道你这人这样，而且你跳得真好。好吧，我不会跳舞。
So many. So many. Michael Scott would have the whole bullpen doing some TikTok dance. You know, I learned TikTok dances in my free time and I just never post myself doing them. I know this about you and you're really good. Well, I can't dance.
太多了。真的太多了。迈克尔·斯科特会带着整个开放式办公区的员工跳抖音舞蹈。你知道的，我在空闲时间学抖音舞蹈，只是从来不发自己跳的视频。我了解你这一点，而且你跳得真的很好。好吧，我不会跳舞。
I certainly can't do a TikTok dance. They move so quick. I'm not great. I'm not. You're fantastic. You're being kind. You're being a good BFF. I'm actually not. You're really good.'re being kind, you're being a good BFF. I'm actually not, you're really good. That last one you sent me was so good.
我当然不会跳 TikTok 舞蹈。他们动作太快了。我跳得不太好。我真的不行。你跳得棒极了。你太客气了。你真是个好闺蜜。我其实不行，你真的很厉害。你太客气了，你真是个好闺蜜。我其实不行，你真的很厉害。你上次发给我的那个视频太棒了。
I wish you would share one. It all started with me learning the tap dance routine to Footloose. That kind of kicked it off. It's great exercise. It really is just learning these TikTok dances. And the latest one I learned was the one from the show, Chicago. Yeah, everyone's doing that one.
我希望你能分享一个。这一切都是从我学习《浑身是劲》里的踢踏舞动作开始的。算是从那次开始的。这真的是很好的锻炼。学这些 TikTok 舞蹈确实很有锻炼效果。我最近学的一个是音乐剧《芝加哥》里的。对，每个人都在跳那个。
Yeah, I figured it out, I did it. I'm proud of it. I think you're really good at it. I don't think I'll ever post it. I love the part where you did. I don't think it's gonna end up on Office Ladies this week, but I don't know. I like the part where you did your hands that way
对，我学会了，我做到了。我为自己感到骄傲。我觉得你跳得真的很好。我想我永远都不会把它发出来。我很喜欢你做那个动作的部分。我觉得它这周不会出现在《办公室姐妹》里，不过我也说不准。我喜欢你把手那样摆的那部分，
and then you did your hands this way. It was like really fast. You know what, it was really hard for me to figure that out. Ta ta ta ta ta. I thought. You know what it was really hard for me to figure that out. I thought it was so good. It was hard for me to figure out. I could not do it. And it got my heart rate up.
然后你又把手这样摆。动作真的很快。你知道吗，我弄懂那个动作真的很难。哒哒哒哒哒。我以为。你知道吗，我弄懂那个动作真的很难。我觉得它太棒了。我很难弄懂它。我根本做不到。而且我的心跳都加快了。
Well there you go. And I enjoyed myself. There you go. That was a tangent I wasn't expecting to go on. Well now people are going to want to see it so. It'll never see the light of day. It's for me. It's my joy and for you because I send them to you.
好吧，那就这样。而且我很享受。那就这样。这是一个我没料到的题外话。好吧，现在大家都会想看了，所以。它永远不会见天日。这是给我的。这是我的快乐源泉，也是给你的，因为我发给你了。
You're my audience of one. Well, I think you're phenomenal. Thank you. Sensei Billy and Dwight are about to begin the belt ceremony. Dwight kind of is like thrusting his hips towards Sensei Billy, which is making this very difficult to take the belt off.
你是我唯一的观众。好吧，我觉得你太厉害了。谢谢。比利师傅和德怀特即将开始系腰带仪式。德怀特有点像是在朝比利师傅挺胯，这让解下腰带变得非常困难。
They're just going to have to cut it off. I know we talked about how much fun it was to shoot this with Michael, but I wanted to point out this fan catch from Courtney C. in Torrance, California, because she noticed we did get a giant break on camera. Courtney said, David Wallace is definitely laughing and breaking when Dwight presents the scissors to Sensei Billy. Andy lost it. Oh my gosh, Angela, it's full Mindy. It's like, he's just literally, he's just laughing. Laughing on camera. Yeah, and he was really usually pretty good about it.
他们只能把它剪断了。我知道我们聊过和迈克尔一起拍摄有多么开心，但我特别想指出托兰斯加州的考特尼·C发现的这个穿帮镜头，因为她注意到我们在镜头前确实笑场了。考特尼说，当德怀特把剪刀呈给比利师傅时，大卫·华莱士明显在笑并且笑场了。安迪也笑崩了。哦天哪，安吉拉，这完全是明迪上身。就是，他简直就是，他直接在笑。在镜头前笑场。对，而且他通常在这方面表现得挺好的。
Oh, he was. Yeah. Oh wait, Kate is waving from the sound booth. Kate, do you have something to add about this scene? Fan catch from Kate. As Dwight begins his karate black belt routine, you, I believe as Angela Kinsey, not Angela Martin are fully laughing in the background.
哦，他确实是。对。哦等等，凯特在声音控制室挥手。凯特，你对这个场景有什么要补充的吗？凯特的穿帮发现。当德怀特开始他的空德怀特开始他的空竹，不对，黑带空手道套路时，我坚信作为安吉拉·金西，而不是安吉拉·马丁的你，在背景里笑得前俯后仰。
And so is everyone. Everyone, no one is looking at all serious as he begins this very serious proceeding. I do remember that. I saw you like smirk, Jenna. Oh yeah. Yeah. Here's the thing.
大家也都在笑。每个人，当他开始这个非常严肃的仪式时，没有一个人看起来是严肃的。我确实记得那个。我看到你露出了会心一笑，珍娜。哦，对。对。事情是这样的。
I mean, we talked about this. This was very hard to get through. We have bloopers of it. You know what I mean? And I'm not surprised. I mean, we made our best effort, but. Yeah. Well, good fan catch from Kate.
我的意思是，我们聊过这个。这一段拍下来真的很难。我们有它的NG花絮。你知道我的意思吗？而且我一点也不意外。我的意思是，我们已经尽力了，但是。好吧，凯特发现这个穿帮很棒。
Thank you. Well, Angela's now gonna have a talking head. This is a talking head. This is a talking head I get quoted to me. I've had to sign it like someone wanted me to write it out one time. Basically we learned that Dwight has been practicing karate for years and that Angela used to help him with his strength training when they dated. He would strap her to his chest in a baby bjorn made for fat babies and do lunges across the
谢谢。好吧，安吉拉接下来要有一个单人采访了。这是一个单人采访。这是一个经常被人引用给我的单人采访。我甚至签过名，有一次有人让我把它写下来。基本上我们了解到德怀特多年来一直在练习空手道，安吉拉在他们交往期间曾帮他进行力量训练。他会把她绑在胸前一个专门为胖婴儿设计的婴儿背带上，然后在整个
farm. She felt like she was flying. Here's what I remember about this. There was a serious moment of conversation where they wondered if we could do this. Like a b-roll? Like a b-roll. No. And that they would cut to it and I would be strapped to Rain's chest and you'd be
农场做弓步。她感觉自己就像在飞一样。关于这个，我还记得这些。当时有一段严肃的对话，他们在琢磨我们能不能拍这个。就像个B卷素材？就像个B卷素材。不。他们会剪辑进去，而我会被绑在雷恩的胸前，然后你
doing lunges. There is no way. It never happened, but I was tickled that they were trying to figure it out. This does bring me to some mail we got. Remember when I played my bulls**t cards for the farm? I do. And we told everyone if they had a bulls**t card to play
在做弓步。这绝对不可能。这从来没发生过，但我很高兴他们当时在想方设法把它拍出来。这让我想到了我们收到的一封邮件。还记得我为农场打出“胡扯”牌的时候吗？我记得。我们告诉大家，如果他们手里有“胡扯”牌可以打，
that they could write in and we set up a folder on our website. I do remember. Well, we got one for this episode and here it is. It's from Karen C in Texas and in the subject for what episode she wrote this. I'm not sure the episode number but it's the one where Angela lost everything and has to move in with Oscar. Okay. Okay and here's her bullsh** card and I thought she brought up a good point. I call bullsh** on Angela's downfall because before the senator she was making enough money
他们可以写信过来，我们在网站上建了一个文件夹。我确实记得。好吧，我们为这一集收到了一封，内容是这样的。它来自德克萨斯的凯伦·C，她在邮件主题里写了是哪一集。我不确定是第几集，但就是安吉拉一无所有、不得不搬去和奥斯卡同住的那一集。好吧。好吧，这就是她打出的“胡扯”牌，我觉得她提出了一个很好的观点。我对安吉拉的落魄表示胡扯，因为在参议员事件之前，她赚的钱足够买一套房子，她现在应该也还有足够的钱至少租得起一套公寓。我知道其他人也写信提到了这一点，但接下来是我觉得她真正切中要害的地方。在宾夕法尼亚州，惯例是——虽然不是强制规定，但惯例是在离婚时，婚姻法财产要五五分成。所以安吉拉应该能得到某种和解金。所以对她后来的急转直下表示胡扯。好吧，我知道我们讨论过这个。
to have a house, she still should have enough money to at least afford an apartment. And I know other people wrote this in, but here's the part where I thought she made a good point. In Pennsylvania, it is practiced, it is not a mandate, but it is practiced that in a divorce, everything is 50-50 division of marital law. So Angela would have gotten some sort of settlement. So bullsh-t on her downward spiral. All right, so I know we've discussed this.
我们收到了大量关于此事的邮件，都在讨论人们是否相信安吉拉会沦落到如此赤贫的地步。我们在“办公室姐妹”播客的Instagram上看到了一个有趣的评论。卡西，你能查一下吗？她谈到了她的理论。这是对这种说法的很好的反驳。
We got so much mail about this and whether or not people believe that Angela is so destitute. We did get an interesting comment on our Office Ladies pod Instagram that I saw. Cassie, can you look it up? She kind of talks about her theory. It's a nice rebuttal to this.
对，这是苏茜发来的。她说，我以前在一家离婚律师事务所工作。老实说，离婚真的很花钱。我猜安吉拉在衣橱和其他事情上花了很多钱，因为她把自己视为斯克兰顿的第一夫人。此外，任何一个合格的离婚律师都会告诉参议员，在达成抚养费协议之前去做个亲子鉴定。
Yeah, this is from Suzy. And she said, I used to work for a divorce attorney. And let me tell you, that divorce is expensive. I imagine that Angela was probably spending a lot more money on her wardrobe and other things as she viewed herself as the first lady of Scranton. Also, any divorce attorney worth his salt would have told the senator to get a paternity test
安吉拉在婚前和婚姻期间都有工作，所以她可能没有资格获得配偶赡养费。即使他们没有请离婚律师，她可能也没有多少积蓄，而且育儿成本很高。好吧，我喜欢这个。对，我喜欢这两种对这个剧情走向的补充，以及为什么安吉拉可能会陷入困境。对，我能理解为什么她的钱和资产，或者她可能从离婚中获得的任何潜在资金，可能也被套牢了。
before they settled child support. Angela had a job before and during the marriage, so she might not have qualified for spousal support. Even if they didn't use a divorce attorney, she may not have had a lot of savings and childcare cost a lot. All right, I like that. Yeah, I like both of these contributions to this storyline and why Angela might be struggling. Yeah, I could see how her money and assets or any potential money she might get from the divorce might be tied up as well.
就像她可能还没拿到这些款项一样。这事发生得太突然了。对。嗯。有太多事情正在发生。而且那个参议员可能很狡猾，就像……哦，参议员百分之百很狡猾。绝对的。
Like maybe she's not getting these payments yet. This is very fresh. Yeah. Mm-hmm. There's a lot going on. And the senator might have been sneaky and like... Oh, the senator was 100% sneaky. For sure.
哦天哪，克里德·布拉顿在试图给我打电话。接听。好吧，我错过了。你想让我回给他吗？当然，因为我太喜欢他在我们录播客录到一半时给我们打电话了。嘿，帕克特。克里多，你打来的时候我们正在录播客，你又连线我和珍娜了。你发的那段猫咪视频，说实话，那会缠着我的。确实如此。我得分享一下。克里德，你在忙什么？
Oh my God, Creed Bratton is trying to call me. Answer. Well, I missed it. Do you want me to call him back? Well sure because I love when he calls us when we're in the middle of podcasting. Hey Puckett. Creed-o you called we're podcasting you're on with me and Jenna again. That cat video you sent I mean seriously that's gonna haunt me. That's what it did. I'll have to share it. Creed what are you up to?
我在这边跑场子，琢磨着去欧洲、爱尔兰、英国等地演出的喜剧包袱。我刚刚接到一个电话，能聊聊吗？我接到电话，《洛杉矶时报》要做一篇关于这张专辑的文章。太棒了。他们正在邀请我的办公室同事们发表一些评论，谈谈我当年玩音乐时的情景。所以雷恩和布莱恩正准备做一个简短的连线。我打电话是想看看你们愿不愿意和他们聊聊。百分之百，克里德。百分之百。好的。
I'm running my sets here, trying to figure out the comedy bits for Europe and Ireland and England and stuff. And I got a call, can we talk? I got a call LA Times is doing an article on the album. Awesome. And they're asking office mates of mine to make some comments about what it was like when I was playing music. So Rain and Brian are going to do a quick set up. I'm calling you to see if you would talk to them. A hundred percent Creed. A hundred percent. Okay.
你可以把我的电话号码给他们。好的，我可以把你电话号码给我经纪人，让她和他们协调吗？可以。你的巡演什么时候开始？我想是10月3号，3号或5号在诺丁汉。好的。然后第二场演出是在英国，准确地说是伦敦。
You can give them my phone number. Okay, can I give you your phone number to my publicist and she can coordinate it with them? Yes. When does your tour start? I think October 3rd, third or fifth in Nottingham. Okay. And then second show is in England, so in London rather.
你们听到了吗，“办公室姐妹”的听众们。克里德要来欧洲了。你们一定要去他的演出现场。他棒极了。还有免费的炸鱼薯条。免费的炸鱼薯条？真的吗？假的。假的。
You heard that, office ladies listeners. Creed is coming to Europe. You have to go see his show. He's fantastic. And free fish and chips. Free fish and chips? Really? No. No.
我刚才还真挺兴奋的。好吧，克里德，我们还要继续录播客，但我们爱你，也想念你——哦，去录那个播客吧！嗨，简，嗨，克里德。我跟你说过我猫咪看到那个视频时的反应吗？哦，我想看看，我想看看。现在太晚了，它不会有同样的反应了，但如果我能录下视频——哦，我女儿在出门去脊椎指压治疗师那里的路上，手机放在她的钱包里。突然她上了车，手机掉回了后座。她听到了那个声音。视频播放了，她不知怎么按到了，开始播放猫咪的视频。她在窗外寻找那个声音是从哪里传来的。
I got really excited. All right, Creed, well well we're gonna do the podcast but we love you and we miss you oh go do that podcast hi Jan hi Creed I told you my cat's reaction when I played that video well I wanted to see I wanted to see was too late now it wouldn't react the same way but if I could have had a video oh my daughter on, she's walking out to the car to go to the chiropractor and the phone's in her purse. And all of a sudden she gets in the car, it's back in the back seat. She hears that noise there. It went off, she hit it
克里德，我试一下，我再播放一次，看看我猫咪的反应是不是还跟以前一样，既然已经过去几天了，然后我发给你，我把它的反应视频发给你。哦，请务必发给我！天哪，我觉得那绝对是个千载难逢的宝贝。好吧，克里德，我们爱你，我们过会儿聊。爱你们，女孩们。好的，亲爱的。好的，再见。
somehow, it starts playing the cat. She's looking out the windows for that sound. Where it was coming from. Creed I'm gonna try I'll play it again and I'll see if my cat reacts the same way since it's been a few days and I'll send it to you I'll send you a video of his reaction. Oh please do please do I mean my god I don't think that's lightning in a bottle that thing. Alright Creed we love you I'll talk to you soon. Love you girls. Okay, hun. All right, bye.
再见。啊，我最喜欢的邻居，克里德·布拉顿。他要去欧洲了。对。80岁还在巡演。太神奇了。太神奇了。好了各位，官方消息。
Bye. Aw, it's my favorite neighbor, Creed Braden. He's going to Europe. Yeah. 80, touring. Amazing. Amazing. All right everyone, it is official.
德怀特是一名黑带了。是的，他有一套精心编排的——你管这叫什么，他在整个办公室里表演的一套动作。是的，我们和迈克尔聊过这个。这真的是一场永无止境的表演，史蒂夫·伯吉斯告诉我们，我们确实请了一位特技协调员。他叫约翰·梅德林，是一位空手道和徒手格斗专家。
Dwight is a black belt. Yes, he has an elaborate, what would you call it, routine he does throughout the office. Yes, we talked about this with Michael. It is a truly never ending display, and Steve Burgess told us that we did bring in a stunt coordinator. It was John Medlin, who was a specialist in karate
他在拍摄前和雷恩合作过，但同样真实的是，雷恩其实是现场即兴为自己编排了整套动作。我觉得头撞植物的决定完全是雷恩的即兴发挥。是的，潘和吉姆在最后的那个对视并不是剧本里写好的。我太喜欢那个了。我特别喜欢他做那种手部动作的时候，潘的表情就像是在说：不，今天不行，德怀特。没错。
and hand-to-hand combat. He worked with Rain before the shoot but it's also true that Rain kind of made up this whole sequence for himself on the day. I feel like the choice to headbutt the plant was all Rain. Yeah that little stare down between Pam and Jim at the end was not scripted. I loved that. I loved it when he was doing his like hand motion and Pam is like, no, not today Dwight. Exactly.
事实上，剧本里唯一的场景描述只有这个，引述如下：“德怀特在办公室里踢踢打打，离克拉克和菲利斯太近了。”就是这样。就是这样。剧本里就写了这些。上面还写着埃丝特兴奋地跳起来，把双腿盘在他腰上。
In fact, the only scripted scene description was this, quote, Dwight kicks around the office a little too close to Clark and Phyllis. That's it. That's it. That's what it said. It also said that Esther proudly jumps and wraps her legs around him.
是的，剧本里写了。他们只是拥抱了一下，然后我们发现她管德怀特叫“小朱伊·布鲁”，太尴尬了。超级尴尬，我很高兴你这么说。我不喜欢。抱歉，这真的超级尴尬。不，你知道吗？德怀特才不是，他才不想被叫
Yeah, scripted. They just did a hug, and then we find out that she calls Dwight Shrewberry Blue, cringe. Super cringe, I'm so glad you said that. I didn't like it. I'm sorry, it's super cringe. No, and you know what? Dwight is not, he doesn't want to be called
那种幼稚的昵称。不，而且你知道吗？什么？如果你给伴侣起个幼稚的昵称，请留到办公室外面再叫。我不需要知道这些幼稚的昵称。不，而且你知道吗？什么？如果你给伴侣起个幼稚的昵称，请留到办公室外面再叫。我不需要知道它。不？不。
those baby names. No, and also you know what? What? If you call your partner a baby name, save it for out of the office. I don't need to be called those baby names. No, and also you know what? What? If you call your partner a baby name, save it for out of the office. I don't need to know it. No? No.
你难道更希望她叫他“亲爱的”吗？不，不！求求你，别把我扯进去。你知道的，我真的很高兴我们能和迈克尔聊聊这些场景。他真的是个超级好的人。你知道吗，安吉拉，我和李在纽约街头的暑假偶遇他的那个故事。
Would you have preferred that she call him lover? No, no! Please, don't loop me in. You know, I'm really so glad that we got to talk to Michael about these scenes. He is seriously the nicest guy. And you know, Angela, this story of how me and Lee ran into him on our summer vacation on the streets of New York City.
对，你们当时好像正好遇到红灯。你和李站在他和他的妻子旁边。那真是一个非常纽约的时刻。我们俩是从同一家艺术电影院走出来的。我们看的不是同一部电影，但我们是同时走出来的。我们就聊了起来。他们人太好了。我们聊了聊看过的电影，
Yeah, you guys were like at a red light. You and Lee standing next to him and his wife. It was a New York moment, truly. We had both come out of the same like art house movie theater. We hadn't seen the same movie, but we were coming out at the same time. We get to chatting. They are so lovely. We're talking about the movies we saw.
我们聊到，哦，迈克尔和我都做了重看播客。你知道的，他和他的妻子维多利亚刚刚在纽约开了一家酒吧。她亲自做了所有的室内设计。里面每周一还有现场爵士乐表演。我们当时就想，哦天哪，我们一定要去看看。所有这些都发生了。对吧？对。我们从来没有
We're talking about how, oh, Michael and I both did rewatch podcasts. You know, his wife Victoria and he, they just opened up a bar in New York. She did all the interior design for it. It has like live jazz music on Mondays. We're like, oh my gosh, we're going to have to check this out. All of this happens. Right? Yeah. We never
提过他演过《办公室》。这根本没被提起来。然后我从暑假回家，心想，我们的第一集回归剧集是什么？我打开一看，天哪，就是他，真的是他。他就是比利师傅。是的，我当时就想，哦天哪。这太诡异了。
mentioned the fact that he was on the office. This doesn't come up. Then I get home from our summer vacations and I'm like, oh, what's our first episode back? I pop it on and there he is, it's him. He's Sensei Billy. Yes, I was like, oh my gosh. This is so weird.
提到了他出演《办公室》这件事。这事儿一直没播。然后我从暑假回家，心想，哦，我们回归的第一集是什么？我打开一看，真的是他，就是他。他是比利师傅。没错，当时我就想，哦天哪。这太奇怪了。
I just ran into him. And then you reached out and he was so gracious. Yes, he was like, sure, I'd love to chat about it. I really wanna go to his club. Oh lady, for sure. Jazz music on a Monday night in New York City, are you kidding me? I'm in. Yeah. Angela Martin. Are you kidding me? I'm in
我刚碰见他。然后你联系了他，他非常爽快。对，他说，没问题，我很乐意聊聊这个。我真的很想去他的俱乐部。哦，天哪，当然想去。周一晚上的纽约市爵士乐，你在开玩笑吧？我加入。太棒了。安吉拉·马丁。你在开玩笑吧？我加入。
Yeah, Angela Martin would not be in but I am in we are in you know what? I'm gonna tell you the name of it everybody in New York or traveling to New York. You should check it out It is called Scarlet. It is in Manhattan at the corner of 83rd and Amsterdam Okay, and they have a special drink, that is a nod to the White Lotus. Oh. Because he was on season two. Yeah. Yeah.
是的，安吉拉·马丁不会加入，但我加入了，我们加入了。你知道吗？我要告诉你们它的名字，所有在纽约或去纽约旅游的人。你们应该去看看。它叫斯嘉丽（Scarlet）。它在曼哈顿，位于第83街和阿姆斯特丹大道的拐角处。好了，他们有一种特调饮品，是向《白莲花》致敬的。哦。因为他出演了第二季。对。对。
Yeah. Well, Jim and David Wallace are now going to have a chat in the conference room. David is impressed that Jim would set his personal goals aside to focus on his marriage. Yeah. Isn't this when he says he knows some people like wouldn't change their golf schedule for their marriage? Yeah. How are those marriages? Yeah how's that working out for you? My question. Clark is watching
是的。好吧，吉姆和大卫·华莱士现在要在会议室聊天了。大卫对吉姆把个人目标放在一边以专注于婚姻感到印象深刻。对。这不是他说他认识的一些人甚至不会为了婚姻改变高尔夫日程的时候吗？对。那些婚姻怎么样了？对，这事对你效果怎么样？我的问题。克拉克正在看着
this he's very suspicious of Jim he's like you know what I bet he came back here to like take over the job like not to be here with Pam and Dwight defends Jim and says, no, Pam is actually really cool. I loved that. I did too. It was so sweet. And this is where Dwight shares that, you know,
这一幕，他对吉姆非常怀疑。他想，你知道吗？我敢打赌他回这里是为了接管这份工作，而不是为了和帕姆在一起。而德怀特为吉姆辩护，说，不，帕姆其实真的很酷。我喜欢这个。我也是。太甜了。这就是德怀特分享他（的心路历程），你知道的，
he used to want to be the branch manager, but he's made too many mistakes and he thinks Jim would be a fine manager. So we're seeing this really just full circle for Dwight of like his journey and wanting this position. But then back in the conference room, David shares that he's for Dwight of like his journey and wanting this position. But then back in the conference room, David shares that he's considering Dwight as Andy's replacement and Jim says
他曾经想成为分公司经理，但他犯了太多错误，他认为吉姆会是一个不错的经理。所以我们看到了德怀特关于他的这段旅程和想要这个职位的真正圆满的闭环。但回到会议室后，大卫分享说他在考虑让德怀特取代安迪，而吉姆则说
it should absolutely be Dwight. Yeah, David had had a sidebar conversation with Sensei Billy during Dwight's whole routine and Sensei Billy said he was one of the most loyal, dedicated, odd guys that he'd ever met. But I think David's really seeing how much Dwight loves and cares for this company. Now we're going to have a scene that I found very curious simply because of the pairing of people that enter Andy's office. Yeah, this is an odd grouping that we've never seen before.
绝对应该让德怀特上。是的，大卫在德怀特整套流程进行期间和比尔师傅进行了私下交谈，比尔师傅说他是他见过最忠诚、最敬业、最古怪的人之一。但我认为大卫真的看到了德怀特有多么热爱和关心这家公司。接下来我们要看一个我感到非常好奇的场景，仅仅是因为进入安迪办公室的人员搭配。是的，这是一个我们从未见过的奇怪组合。
We have never seen Nellie and Kevin in cahoots in a way. Yes, they have teamed up to confront Andy and again try to convince him not to leave Dunder Mifflin. They sort of say, what if you stayed here and you really gave it a go? You could achieve the fame and immortality simply by being the best manager in the history of this branch. How about that? No.
我们从未见过内莉和凯文以某种方式勾结在一起。是的，他们联手对抗安迪，再次试图说服他不要离开邓德·米夫林。他们某种程度上说，如果你留下来，真的尝试一下会怎么样？你可以通过成为这个分公司历史上最好的经理来获得名望和不朽。觉得怎么样？不。
Andy's not hearing it. And then Oscar's gonna have a talking head that I thought was so hilarious because Oscar Nunez's performance was perfect. Oscar says, no, I don't think he can make it as an actor, but also he can't make it as an employee in an office. So why not go nuts with it? That's very funny.
安迪根本听不进去。然后奥斯卡会有一个访谈，我觉得太搞笑了，因为奥斯卡·努涅斯的表演太完美了。奥斯卡说，不，我不认为他能成为一名演员，但同时他也无法成为办公室里的员工。所以为什么不疯狂一把呢？这太搞笑了。
And he is also facing out. Did anyone face in? It doesn't sound like it. In Living the Dream Part II, someone is facing in. I will save it. Save it. All right, now we're gonna have a scene at Pam's desk. Jim is gonna come up.
而且他也是朝外的。有人朝里吗？听起来好像没有。在《活出梦想（下）》中，有人是朝里的。我先不说。先不说。好吧，现在我们在帕姆的桌子旁有一个场景。吉姆要走过来。
He's kind of just, it's a flirty excuse to come talk to her. It's very cutesy. He's asking about some sticky notes, but I believe it's going to reveal a very big thing about Pam. What is that? Is Pam the sauce lady of the office? She has a salt packet in her desk.
他有点像，这只是一个跟她说话的调情借口。非常可爱。他在打听一些便签的事，但我相信这将会揭示关于帕姆的一个非常大的事情。那是什么？帕姆是办公室里的酱料女士吗？她的办公桌里有一包盐。
I feel like she's one ketchup pack away. She's the sauce lady. She might be. I want you guys to know that there was a very big note that went to both John and I before we started this episode. And the note came from Greg. And it was that Jim should be 100% happy. Yeah. There is no hint of regret, no hint of strife between this couple,
我觉得她离一包番茄酱只有一步之遥。她就是酱料女士。她可能真的是。我想让你们知道，在我们开始这集之前，有一条非常重要的留言发给了我和约翰。这条留言来自格雷格。内容是吉姆应该100%开心。对。没有一丝遗憾，这对夫妻之间没有任何争吵的迹象，
that this whole episode, Jim and Pam, but particularly Jim, is very happy with this decision to be back at Dunder Mifflin. We wanted this to be very clear. You're not wondering. That's absolutely how it read to me. And I was happy, I was like relieved. I feel like as an audience member re-watching,
整集节目中，吉姆和帕姆，尤其是吉姆，对回到邓德·米夫林的这个决定非常高兴。我们希望这一点非常明确。你不用去猜。这绝对就是我的读后感。而且我很开心，我感到如释重负。我觉得作为一个重温节目的观众，
I was so stressed about Jim and Pam that in this episode I could relax. That was the idea. Dwight is now gonna go into the kitchen where he meets Andy, and they're both sort of congratulating each other, you know, like, hey, Dwight, this is a big day for you. Andy's like, it's a big day for you.
我对吉姆和帕姆感到如此焦虑，以至于在这集里我可以放松下来。这就是本意。德怀特现在要走进厨房，在那里他遇到了安迪，他们都在互相祝贺，你知道的，比如，嘿，德怀特，这对你来说是个大日子。安迪则说，这对你来说也是个大日子。
Yeah, they both enter the kitchen whistling. That's how excited they are about their lives, I guess. And I wondered if the whistling was scripted. It was. Oh, it says they both enter whistling. Dwight is also now going to try to talk Andy out of going. He says, listen, I have everything to gain by you leaving, but don't go, please.
是的，他们都吹着口哨走进了厨房。我猜他们对自己的生活就是这么兴奋。我想知道吹口哨是不是剧本里写的。是的。哦，剧本里写着他们俩吹着口哨走进来。德怀特现在也要试图劝说安迪不要离开。他说，听着，你离开对我最有好处，但请不要走。
I've seen you perform. Dear God, don't quit your day job. And then Andy has this response, which I just love Ed Helms so much. This made me laugh. In a very cockney accent, he says, nothing is impossible to him who will try. Alex is great if he were cockney. I cannot do a very good cockney accent but
我看过你的表演。天哪，千万别辞掉你的正职。然后安迪有了这样的回应，我太喜欢埃德·赫尔姆斯了。这逗笑了我。他用非常浓重的伦敦东区口音说，世上无难事，只怕有心人。如果他真是伦敦东区人，那可太棒了。我学不好伦敦东区口音，但是
Ed's is great and I just love that that's how he chose to say that quote. And then Andy has this talking head where he says, I'm gonna make it. Every person that has been on Conan has a crazy story about how they made it. Every person. Yeah, that's because every person who's on Conan made it. You know, I have to say though, when you try to do something like this, it does serve you to have a little delusion. I mean, nothing
埃德的口音太棒了，我就是喜欢他选择用这种方式说出那句名言。然后安迪有一个访谈，他说，我会成功的。每一个上过柯南秀的人都有一个关于他们是如何成功的疯狂故事。每一个人。对，那是因为所有上柯南秀的人都成功了。你知道，我不得不说，当你尝试做这样一件事时，带有一点妄想确实对你有帮助。我的意思是，没有什么
makes you get in your car and drive across the country with your denim vest on, ready to take the world. That's right. I mean, there is, there's ambition, but there's a healthy amount of delusion. So Andy's not wrong. And you do have to be your own champion, even when other people don't see it in you. You have to see it in yourself. It's true. I thought a lot about my early days watching this episode.
能让你坐进车里，穿着牛仔背心横穿全国，准备好征服世界。没错。我的意思是，有野心，但也要有适度的妄想。所以安迪并没有错。而且你必须成为自己的支持者，即使别人在你身上看不到这一点。你必须在自己身上看到这一点。真的。看这一集的时候，我想到了很多我的早期经历。
I remember telling my manager at 1-800-DENTIST that I was going to quit 1-800-DENTIST to focus on my one-woman show. And I did. You were Andy. I was Andy. I wrote a one-woman show full of characters. I did a whole bunch of characters. Oh gosh.
我记得我曾对1-800-DENTIST（牙医预约热线）的经理说，我要辞去1-800-DENTIST的工作，专注于我的独角戏。我真的这么做了。你就是安迪。我就是安迪。我写了一出充满角色的独角戏。我演了一大堆角色。哦天哪。
I remember that I was at a job interview. And in the interview I wanted to be very honest and upfront about why I was really here, and it was not to be part of media sales. And so I said, I do feel like I need to tell you that I'm really here pursuing an acting career, so that is gonna be my main focus. I'm really here for that.
我记得当时我在参加一个工作面试。在面试中，我想非常诚实和坦率地说明我真正来这里的目的，而这并不是为了从事媒体销售。所以我说，我觉得我需要告诉你，我来这里真的是为了追求演艺事业，所以这将是我的主要重心。我来这里真的是为了这个。
That is gonna be my main focus. I'm really here for that. Yeah. And the person literally said, I think that'll be fine. If it becomes a problem, we'll deal with it. Yeah. Like sort of like, okay, we'll see you tomorrow at nine. Don't think I'm gonna have to worry.
这将是我的主要重心。我来这里真的是为了这个。对。那个人字面意思是说，我觉得这没问题。如果这成了问题，我们会处理的。对，就像那种，好吧，我们明天九点见。我觉得我不用担心。
Well, my manager at 1-800-Dennis said, anytime you wanna come back. Well, my manager at 1-800-Dennis said, any time you wanna come back. No, you're welcome. I was like, okay. And I remember like driving in my car, leaving there being like, I'm never gonna go back. You'll see, my one-woman show is gonna be the talk of the town.
好吧，我在1-800-DENTIST的经理说，随时欢迎你回来。好吧，我在1-800-DENTIST的经理说，随时欢迎你回来。不，随时欢迎。我当时想，好吧。我记得开车离开的时候心想，我再也不会回去了。走着瞧吧，我的独角戏会成为全城的热门话题。
All my characters. Oh my goodness. Well, most people didn't maybe totally support our delusions. Aaron certainly does not support Andy's. Well Andy says I'm gonna ask you, you're honest Aaron right? Aaron cannot tell a lie. Yeah. And she says pretty bluntly that she's worried that he might become homeless or even starve. Yeah and this is gonna finally take the wind out of Andy's sails. Mm-hmm. Andy walks into the conference room and before he could even say anything, David says, you know
我所有的角色。哦天哪。好吧，大多数人可能并不完全支持我们的妄想。艾琳绝对不支持安迪的。好吧，安迪说我要问你，艾琳，你很诚实对吧？艾琳不会说谎。对，她相当直白地表示，她担心他可能会无家可归甚至挨饿。对，这终于让安迪泄了气。嗯哼。安迪走进了会议室，在他还没来得及说什么之前，大卫就说，你知道
what, you can stay on as a salesman. Yeah. And I'm sad for Andy. He was so excited at the beginning of this episode. Well don't worry, I know. There's part two coming. Part two is coming. We're going to end on a big cliffhanger. David Wallace is going to call Dwight into the conference room. Dun, dun, dun. Dun, dun, dun.
吗，你可以作为销售员留下来。对。我为安迪感到难过。他在这一集开始时是那么兴奋。好吧，别担心，我知道。第二部分要来了。第二部分要来了。我们要在一个巨大的悬念中结束。大卫·华莱士将把德怀特叫进会议室。咚，咚，咚。咚，咚，咚。
To be continued. Yes. We did get a fan catch for this very final moment of Dwight shutting the door behind him. It's from Xenia W. in British Columbia, and also Summer P. from St. Charles, Missouri. They have a mom detective's moment for us in this very final shot of this episode.
未完待续。是的。对于德怀特关上身后门这个最后的时刻，我们确实收到了粉丝的发现。它来自不列颠哥伦比亚省的西妮娅·W.（Xenia W.），以及密苏里州圣查尔斯的萨默·P.（Summer P.）。在这集的最后一个镜头中，他们为我们贡献了一个妈妈侦探的高光时刻。
What is it? I'm gonna tell you, I'm also gonna tell you ahead of time, this one is gonna go unsolved as well. Oh, okay. So nothing new. Correct. At 20 minutes and 58 seconds, as Dwight closes the conference room door to talk to David Wallace There is a single trailing drip of something on the wall behind Dwight's head
是什么？我要告诉你们，我还要提前告诉你们，这个疑案也将悬而未决。哦，好吧。所以没什么新鲜的。没错。在20分58秒时，当德怀特关上会议室的门去和大卫·华莱士谈话时，德怀特头部后面的墙上有一滴孤零零的液体流痕。
Oh, they can't tell what it is and it's driving them crazy. They want to know is it coffee? Is it chocolate sauce? Is it part of a deleted scene? Is it head high? It's about, yeah, it is. Mm-hmm. Huh. Was it perhaps splattered there from a crew member and no one caught it? Jenna, Angela, can the mom detectives solve this? I will go back and re-watch it.
哦，他们看不出那是什么，这快把他们逼疯了。他们想知道是咖啡吗？是巧克力酱吗？是删减片段的一部分吗？和头一样高吗？大概是，是的。嗯哼。难道是某个剧组人员溅上去的而没有人发现吗？珍娜，安吉拉，妈妈侦探能解开这个谜团吗？我会回去重看一遍。
I'll zoom in on it. I looked at it, I have a picture of it. Oh, let's see it. See if it'll help you. Okay. I almost drew a circle around it. Oh, I Think it looks like Sharpie No, it looks like a drip. No, there's a drip at the bottom. Look at it There's a little bubble of drip. Where the ink like makes the bigger dot. Why would someone draw Sharpie on the wall? I don't think they meant to.
我会把它放大。我看过了，我有一张照片。哦，让我们看看。看看它能不能帮到你。好的。我差点在它周围画了个圈。哦，我觉得它看起来像记号笔。不，它看起来像一滴液体。不，底部有一滴。看这里。有一个小小的液体泡泡。墨水汇聚成较大的那个点的地方。为什么会有人在墙上画记号笔？我觉得他们不是故意的。
I don't think it's Sharpie. I wanna look at it again. It looks like black Sharpie to me. Oh, when you really zoom in on it. Mm-hmm. I see what you're doing there. Okay, well. My theory is it's Sharpie.
我不认为那是记号笔。我想再看一遍。在我看来它就像黑色的记号笔。哦，当你真正把它放大看时。嗯哼。我看到你在干什么了。好吧，好吧。我的理论是那是记号笔。
Xenia Summer, when you zoom in on it, I don't know, what if, when you zoom in on it, I don't know, what if when it's a video it's moving? I'm gonna have to re-watch it to be continued. To be continued just like this episode. Just like this episode. I do wanna give a shout out to the writer of this episode, Nikki Schwartz Wright.
西妮娅，萨默，当你把它放大时，我不知道，如果，当你把它放大时，我不知道，如果它在视频里是会动的呢？我得重新看一遍。未完待续。未完待续，就像这一集一样。就像这一集一样。我确实想向本集的编剧尼基·施瓦茨-赖特（Nikki Schwartz Wright）致敬。
She's fantastic, we traded text, and I told her how special this episode is to me because I loved, loved getting to see the range of emotion in Angela Martin. A lot happens for her in this episode and it had to build and grow and I thought Nikki wrote it so well. And she wrote me back and said that she has bronchitis or she would have left us a voice memo.
她太棒了，我们互发了短信，我告诉她这一集对我来说有多特别，因为我非常非常高兴能看到安吉拉·马丁丰富的感情色彩。她在这一集中经历了很多事情，这些情绪需要层层递进和发展，我觉得尼基写得太好了。她回短信给我说她得了支气管炎，否则她就会给我们留一条语音备忘录了。
Aw. But in the text she praised our writers room and said they truly wrote these episodes as a group and she didn't want to take any of the credit. I know. So sweet. She was really happy that they brought me joy and she's just so talented in a class act and I just wanted to say Nikki I hope you feel better and thanks for giving Angela Martin such a great episode. And it's really just gonna get even better too
噢。但在短信中，她赞扬了我们的编剧室，并表示他们真的是作为一个团队来写这些剧集的，她不想居功自傲。我懂的。太贴心了。她很高兴这些带给我快乐，她非常有才华，而且为人正直，我只想说尼基，希望你早日康复，感谢你给安吉拉·马丁写了这么棒的一集。而且接下来真的会变得更好，
in the second half in terms of that Angela Martin emotion. Some big stuff is coming. I cried, we'll talk about it next week. Yeah. Well, I wanna give a big thank you again to Michael Imperioli and one more shout out for Michael and Victoria's Bar, Scarlett. And also I want to thank Ed Helms for chatting with us about those headshots.
在第二半部分中，就安吉拉·马丁的情感而言。一些重磅内容要来了。我哭了，我们下周聊这个。好的，我再次向迈克尔·因佩里奥利（Michael Imperioli）表示巨大的感谢，并再次向迈克尔和维多利亚的酒吧“斯嘉丽”致敬。我也要感谢埃德·赫尔姆斯和我们聊了那些演员头像照。
You know, season two of Ed's podcast, Snafu, is out now. Snafu is a podcast about history's greatest screw ups. And this season they are deep diving on Medburg, which is the story of a daring heist that exposed a colossal FBI snafu. Ooh, you can listen wherever you get your podcasts. And also a big thank you to Steve Burgess for answering our behind the scenes questions. And he gave us great photos from the set this week,
你知道，埃德的播客节目《乱七八糟》（Snafu）第二季现在已经上线了。《Snafu》是一个关于历史上最大搞砸事件的播客。这个季度他们正在深入探讨梅德堡事件（Medburg），这是一个大胆的抢劫案的故事，揭露了联邦调查局（FBI）的一次惊天大乌龙。哦，你可以在任何收听播客的地方收听。还要非常感谢史蒂夫·伯吉斯（Steve Burgess）回答了我们关于幕后的问题。他这周给我们提供了非常棒的片场照片，
including one of Kelly's bridal shower and some of Sensei Billy and Dwight in their scenes. We'll share those all in stories. And thanks to all of you for writing in with your questions and comments. We'll see you next week for Live in the Dream, Part Two. Who knows, maybe Creed will call again. He might.
包括一张凯利的婚前单身派对的照片，以及一些比尔师傅和德怀特在片场的照片。我们都会在快拍中分享这些。感谢所有写信提出问题和评论的大家。我们下周再见，收看《活出梦想（下）》。谁知道呢，说不定克里德又会打电话来呢。他可能会的。
All right, have a good one. Have a good one. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is a present-day office newsroom, and we're here to help you get to know the latest in office news. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fischer and Angela Kinsey.
好了，祝你们过得愉快。祝你们过得愉快。感谢收听《办公室女士》。《办公室女士》是一个当下的办公室新闻室，我们在这里帮助你了解办公室新闻的最新动态。感谢收听《办公室女士》。《办公室女士》是Audience出品的节目，由珍娜·菲舍尔和安吉拉·金西制作。
Our executive producer is Cassie Jerkins. Our audio engineer is Sam Kiefer and our associate producer is Ainsley Bubbaco. Odyssey's executive producers are Jenna Weiss-Berman and Leah Reese Leah Reese Dennis. Office Ladies is mixed and mastered by Chris Basil. Our theme song is Ruppertree by Creed Bratton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们的执行制片人是卡西·杰金斯（Cassie Jerkins）。我们的音频工程师是萨姆·基弗（Sam Kiefer），我们的副制片人是艾因斯利·巴巴科（Ainsley Bubbaco）。Audience的执行制片人是珍娜·韦斯-伯曼（Jenna Weiss-Berman）和莉亚·里斯·丹尼斯（Leah Reese Dennis）。《办公室女士》由克里斯·巴西尔（Chris Basil）混音和母带制作。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿（Creed Bratton）的《鲁珀特树》（Ruppertree）。本集还没有评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可发表评论。